bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat dans un instant nous
allons regagner l'hémicycle car vous le
savez l'examen du projet de loi ouvrant
le mariage aux personnes de même sexe se
poursuit cette après-midi au Sénat hier
après plus de 10h de débat l'article
premier a été voté par les sénateurs cet
article et bien modifie le Code civil et
consacre le principe du mariage pour les
personnes de même sexe alors cette
après-midi la discussion reprend à
l'article premier bis qui concerne
l'adoption plinière et là aussi les
débats s'annoncent passionnés alors tout
de suite direction l'hémicycle bon
après-midi à tous Je je voudrais faire
trois remarques à partir des grande
thématique que vous avez pu avoir au
cours de vos interventions
euh vos interventions m'inspirent déjà
une première remarque heureusement qu'il
y a au fond ce débat sur l'ouverture du
mariage et de l'adoption aux homosexuels
parce que c'est une façon et on peut
remercier au fond les homosexuels de
revisiter l'ensemble du droit de la
famille on
évoque le statut du beau-parent on
évoque la la question des nouvell
filiation on évoque la réforme de
manifestement ça vous intéresse
pas non mais je le dis très
clairement vous vous vous voulez qu'on
vous réponde et qu'on soit dans un débat
éventuellement constructif et vous
lorsqu'on parle du
fond ça ne vous intéresse pas donc moi
je vous parle du fond et donc je je on
est êtes en train d'évoquer vous avez
évoqué le statut du beau-parent vous
avez évoqué la question des nouvelles
fili
vous avez évoqué monsieur Géard l'a fait
avec beaucoup de justesse sur la réforme
de l'adoption car effectivement on peut
légitimement se poser la question d'une
véritable réforme de l'adoption au
regard des évolutions sur lesquelles je
reviendrai dans un instant des de la
réduction de l'adoption internationale
de l'existence d'un droit spécifique
français qui se partage entre adoption
simple et adoption plinière et en même
temps sur la situation d'enfants
monsieur gellard l'a dit de d'enfants
qui sont à la fois sortis de leur
famille mais qui ne retourneront pas
dans leur famille biologique mais qui ne
sont pas en même temps adoptables et
dont on sait qu'effectivement il y a une
forme d'érance en tout cas au minimum
affective de famille d'accueil en
famille d'accueil ou de foyer et que
cette situation là vous qui est tant
attaché à l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant n'est franchement pas justement
répondre à l'intérêt supérieur de de
l'enfant donc ce sont des questions qui
sont effectivement des questions de fond
pourquoi nous estimons que ça doit faire
l'objet d'une loi famille c'est parce
que tant je vous l'ai déjà dit mais je
le redis tant qu'il y a des familles
tant qu'il y a une partie de nos
concitoyens qui n'ont pas les mêmes
droits et les mêmes devoirs comment
parler de réforme alors qu'il s'agit de
commencer par donner à tous les mêmes
droits les mêmes devoirs que cela vous
déplaise c'est le principe même de
l'égalité que vous préfériez parler
d'équité c'est votre affaire nous nous
préférons parler d'égalité mais viendra
mais viendra le temps effectivement
d'une loi famille qui s'adressera vous
l'avez dit indifféremment aussi bien aux
familles
hétérosexuelles
qu'homosexuelles et qui effectivement
abordera ces questions de nouvelles
filiation dans leur grande diversité
vous avez évoqué la question de l'accès
aux origines ou du droit de l'enfant à
connaître son histoire originelle ça
fait partie des réflexions et j'ai
presque envie de dire et je vais
rejoindre au moins sur ce point-là
Jean-Luc rosenveg si vous êtes prêt à me
soutenir dans la création d'un ministère
de l'enfance parce que effectivement
nous avons hérité mais depuis des
décennies et des décennies de situations
où l'enfant est perçu tantôt écolier
tantôt collégien tantôt malheureusement
délinquant et que il est ou tantôt
enfant malade et cetera et qu'il est
scindé en tranche mais qu'il n'y a
jamais véritablement de réflexion
globale autour de l'enfant mais je vous
assure alors là je vous soutiendrai dans
ces propositions car je pense
qu'effectivement ça sera une façon de
prendre en compte l'enfant dans sa
globalité et non pas de le cinder comme
nous pouvons le le le le faire à l'heure
actuelle donc ça sera une petite
révolution et c'est absolument
absolument je vous prends au mot
monsieur rafarin chiche chiche qu'il y
ait un véritable ministère de l'enfance
et que nous en définissions les les les
contours le le la deuxième thématique
que vous abordez
c'est la question de l'adoption où là
nous serions dans
l'hypocrisie le mensonge mais j'ai envie
de vous dire mais n'est-ce pas vous qui
ne connaissez pas la réalité des
familles ho
parentales car je suis désolé de vous
dire
aujourd'hui c'est quel que soit le
chiffre que vous preniez de 30000 à
300000 enfants qui vivent déjà dans des
familles homoparentales et pour qui la
ad option par le deuxième parent qui
aujourd'hui n'a aucune reconnaissance
juridique présentera une véritable
sécurisation juridique de ses enfants et
quand j'entends dire quand j'entends
dire que la loi permet déjà de répondre
à cela mais si c'était le si c'était le
cas alors pourquoi dans les familles
recomposées des beaux parents qui
essayent d'avoir un véritable statut n'y
parviennent pas et pourquoi dans le même
temps vous réclamez un statut du
beau-parent il y aurait là une
contradiction c'est-à-dire que pour les
familles homoparentales la loi serait
suffisante mais pour les familles
recomposées il faudrait créer un statut
du beau-parent ou un statut du tiers
donc vous voyez bien que il y a là un
vide juridique qui fait que ce
qu'attendent essentiellement les les les
les familles homoparentales c'est
précisément qu'au travers de l'adoption
le deuxième parent qui est on peut
l'appeler le parent social si ça si même
si cela vous he puisse avoir une
véritable reconnaissance juridique
c'est-à-dire puisse permettre
véritablement à une sécurisation une
protection juridique des enfants qui
vivent dans ces familles homoparentales
et arrêtez de prendre les homosexuels
pour des saut des saut qui laisserai
mais si quand vous dites quand vous
dites quand vous dites quand vous dites
que l'on ne va pas dire à ses enfants ou
qu'on va leur laisser croire qu'il on
est de deux paires ou de de mères c'est
une insulte lorsque vous lorsque vous
laissez croire lorsque vous laissez
croire que les homosexuels attendent
tout de l'adoption internationale ils
savent tout comme vous tout comme vous
lire les chiffres et ceux qui
demanderont un agrément pour adopter de
façon
international seront exactement dans les
mêmes conditions juridiques sociales que
les autres
couples
hétérosexuels je veux dire que justement
sur sur la
l'adoption j'ai entendu des choses qui
n'était pas tout à fait juste c'est
vrai on parle du fond c'est vrai que les
chiffres qui ont été cités en matière
d'adoption internationale vous avez
raison de le dire ça dit par plusieurs
d'entre vous ont été entre 2006 et 2011
divisé par 2 on est passé de 4000 à un
peu moins de 2000 voilà mais je tiens à
vous dire que en matière d'adoption
nationale nous sommes dans une quasi
stabilité voir une légère progression
des enfants adoptables
nationalement en 2006
698 en 2011 76
61 donc voilà je veux dire le la
réflexion elle peut porter sur
l'adoption internationale et à ce titre
laissez croire aussi que les pays qui se
sont engagés déjà dans
l'adoption de de la réforme de
l'ouverture du mariage et de l'adoption
couple de même sexe on vu les adoptions
se rarfi et fausse c'est faux en
Belgique c'est faux au Pays-Bas et c'est
encore plus faux en Espagne en Espagne
je peux vous donner les chiffres c'est
près depuis 2006 c'est près de 160
adoptions par des couples homosexuels
depuis 2006 et je peux même vous dire
que le l'Espagne aujourd'hui est le
troisème pays d'accueil d'enfants
adoptés passant devant la France et
pourquoi parce que en fait c'est a une
véritable réflexion sur ce ce qu'est
devenu aujourd'hui l'adoption
internationale qu'il faut se livrer en
France pour avoir pour mieux informer
les parents qui veulent adopter qu'ils
soient hétérosexuel ou homosexuel et les
services de l'adoption du ministère des
Affaires étrangères n'ont pas trouvé un
seul pays qui ait pris des mesures de
rétorsion à l'égard des couples
hétérosexuels qui souhaite adopter en
leur disant parce que votre pays a
adopté cette loi-là alors vous n'aurez
plus droit à des enfants adoptables donc
cessz de à la fois laisser penser que
les homosexuels pensent qu'ils vont
pouvoir adopter internationalement très
facilement et cesser de faire croire aux
familles hétérosexuelles adoptantes
qu'elles ne vont plus pouvoir adopter ou
que l'adoption va se rarfier parce que
on s'engagerait sur cette voie-là
trème élément c'est l'intérêt supérieur
de
l'enfant l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
tel que vous le concevez et si je le
conçois bien et si je l'ai bien compris
ça se résume à avoir un père une
mère le problème c'est que vous faites
vous
faites je dirais vous vous mettez de de
côté les célibataires qui peuvent
adopter aujourd'hui alors il faut si
vous êtes cohérent supprimer l'adoption
pour les célibataires
ensuite
bah bon ensuite je pense
que pour toutes les familles
monoparentales je pense que les familles
monoparental et leurs enfants
apprécieront et pour et pour les
familles mais si parce que vous partez
d'un principe vous partez d'un principe
qu'il suffit je l'ai déjà dit mais je le
redis qu'il suffit d'être un géniteur ou
une génitrice pour devenir d'emblé un
père et une mère et bien c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que cela c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que cela et c'est bien ce
qui fait que l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant ne se résume pas à être conçu
mais bien qu'il y a ensuite tout
l'aspect éducatif
affectif environnemental qui est qui n'a
rien à voir qui n'a rien à voir avec la
sexualité des parents qui élèvent les
enfants et puis faites attention faites
attention parce que aujourd'hui et les
femmes l'ont suffisamment réclamé que
les pères s'occupent y compris dans leur
plus jeune âge des enfants donc il y a
des pères qui sont en train de materner
comme peut-être il y a des des mères qui
sont en train de
paterner donc vous voyez vous voyez
qu'il y a une telle évolution il y a une
telle évolution que la sexualité des
parents n'a pas grand-chose à voir avec
l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant mais non mais non et puis ça
fait x journée que vous nous répétez
l'altérité mais l'altérité d'un enfant
ne se conçoit-elle que parce que il
aurait une image chez lui masculine et
féminine ça peut peut-être aider on peut
se mettre d'accord là-dessus mais pour
tous les enfants pour tous les enfants
pour tous les enfants moi je suis la
ministre de toutes les familles monsieur
rotillon de toutes de toutes les
familles je je tiens à dire que
l'altérité mais l'altérité ces enfants
qui vivent dans des familles
homoparentales ils ont des
grands-parents ils ont des cousins des
cousines donc l'alérité ils savent très
bien ce que c'est ils savent très bien
ce que c'est donc vous ne pouvez pas
réduire l'altérité à simplement cette
question d'avoir un père et une mère ou
alors je le redis les familles
recomposées les familles monoparentales
sont aussi des victimes pour vous je
vais juste parce que j'ai bien compris
PMA GPA c'est votre light motif je vais
vous parler de
GPA je vais vous parler de
GPA
alors soit moi je ne vous fais pas
l'insulte de ne pas avoir compris les
propos du président de la République
lors de son intervention
télévisée qui est d'une
clarté absolue absolue
puisqu'il a même dit que la
GPA le débat ne serait pas ouvert
pendant son
quinquena et je vous rends attentif à
une
chose parce que vous parlez de GPA vous
parlez de GPA là aussi à propos des
homosexuels mais vous savez les premiers
cas de GPA c'est pas ça n'a pas été
soulevé par les homosexuels ça a été
soulevé par des couples
hétérosexuels qui ont eu recours à la
GPA et bien je vous le dis ne mettez pas
sur le dos des homosexuels toutes les
interrogations qui sont des
interrogations réelles de société mais
si mais si mais si et puis et puis et
puis vous voulez d'un débat
serein nous
aussi je vous cite en parlant du
gouvernement
vous
bidouillez vous
mentez vous êtes marchand
d'illusion vous êtes
irresponsable
hiyppocrite vous vous ridiculisez
hein
décadant moi je vais vous dire je vais
vous dire je vais vous
dire vous êtes dans votre rôle
d'opposition et nous nous avons le cuir
tané mais j'ai envie de vous dire mais
j'ai envie de vous dire mais j'ai envie
de vous dire pensez pensez parce que ce
que vous nous dites je le répète nous
avons le cuirané mais pensez aux
homosexuels et aux enfants qui vivent
dans les familles au B parental et qui
entendent les propos que je vais vous
citer pensez à
cela
je je je vous cite j'ai mis des
guillemets ces enfants troublés par
l'inconnu de leur
naissance mais imaginez imaginez
mettez-vous à la place de ces enfants
qui entendent
ça pensez-vous un seul instant qu'ils
ignorent qu'ils ignorent d'où ils
viennent l'enfant n'est pas un remède
des couples ça s'adresse indifféremment
aux htéros et aux hom seu l'enfant n'est
pas un bien de consommation n'est pas un
objet vous pointez du doigt vous pointez
du doigt les familles homoparentales en
leur disant vous famille homoparental
vous considérez l'enfant comme un objet
ou comme un bien de consommation c'est
très
choquant vous dites vous
dites le double traumatisme chez ses
enfants les carences affectives mais
quand savez-vous vous avez-vous su les
entendre lorsqu'ils ont été
auditionnés je préfère je vous le dis
franchement et je ne parle pas de la
normalité ils apprécieront bien
évidemment je veux dire qu' qu' pire
c'est un manque de respect
ou au mieux de mes connaissan de mes
connaissances des projets parentaux de
ces famille
homoparentale et qu'il serait bien de
commencer par
respecter la force des projets parentaux
qui est souvent celle des ces familles
homoparentales alors si vous voulez un
vrai débat où vous voulez que l'on
échange je vous invite vis-à-vis de ces
familles homoparentales et de leurs
enfants à un peu plus d'humilité et de
modestie si la parole à Madame la
gardessau
la parole est à Madame la Gard merci
monsieur le Président j'allais presque
dire que cette ambiance nous rajunit par
parce que elle est assez potache en fait
elle nous renverrait au tout début du
collège euh sauf que le sauf que le
sujet extrêmement grave le sujet
extrêmement grave et qui vous arrive
parmi certains certains d'entre vous de
tenir des propos euh regrettables
regrettables tristes triste lourd et qui
ne contribue pas au lien social dans la
société qui ne contribue pas au pacte
républicain je me permets de vous le
dire ça concerne certains d'entre vous
ne cherchez pas à diviser le
gouvernement sur cette affaire et ne
croyez pas que en chahutant la
ministre de la Famille et en faisant
croire que vous m'accueillez avec plus
de cordialité que vous allez glisser la
moindre division au sein de ce
gouvernement qui est profondément soudé
autour de ce projet c'est un engagement
du Président de la République avec
lequel nous faisons cor que nous
essayons de porter avec la plus grande
dignité
possible un certain nombre de questions
été posé madame la ministre de la
Famille a répondu à quelques-unes
d'entre elles notamment l'altérité
sexuelle parce que
l'altérité toute seule là ça ne répond
pas à la question ça ça ne s'enferme pas
dans le couple voilà l'autre et l'autre
qui qu'il soit l'autre et l'autre donc
l'altérité sexuelle c'est juste une
forme d'altérité et en fait c'est le nom
que vous donnez abusiv d'ailleurs à la
simple complémentarité sexuelle pour
l'engendrement et l'altérité c'est autre
chose l'altérité c'est l'autre en ce
qu'il est dans son individualité dans sa
singularité l'autre dans son intégrité
humaine et c'est cette altérité qui nous
préoccupe et nous pensons qu'elle n'est
pas fragilisée par l'ouverture de
l'institution du mariage au couple de
même sexe au contraire on en élargit
l'univers monsieur le sénateur Rev
vousvez vous m'avez interrogé mais je
n'ai pas d'illusion quelle que soit la
réponse que nous vous apportons vous
revenez en boucle avec les mêmes
questions mais nous ne sommes pas des
paysé nous avons affronté cet exercice
pendant pratiquement une quinzaine de
jours à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est-à-dire que répondant 10 fois 15
fois 20 fois la 21e fois les députés
avec les mêmes fiches et les mêmes
cartons nous reposaient exactement les
mêmes questions alors c'était la PMA
c'était la GPA il est arrivé mais ça n'a
pas vraiment prospéré il est arrivé
qu'il euh fut question de du clonage
aussi et bon peu imporait les réponses
l'essentiel c'était de durer de même que
vos collègues de l'opposition à
l'Assemblée nationale pour durer nous
ont fait des milliers d'amendements de
suppression de suppression de toute une
série d'articles du Code civil en fait
ces amendements j'en conviens j'en
conviens je vous en donne acte mais si
nous avions si ces amendements avait été
adopté le Code civil aurait fondu nous
avons veillé à l'intégralité à
l'intégrité du Code civil vous avez posé
des questions sur la PMA sur la GPA nous
vous avons répondu nous vous avons
répondu nous sommes sur un texte dont le
périmètre est clair précis il concerne
l'ouverture du mariage et de l'adoption
au couple de même sexe monsieur le
sénateur
leoir me demande nous dit mais pourquoi
vous vous êtes je vous sais là pourquoi
vous vous ne vous êtes pas arrêté au
mariage tout aurait été tellement plus
simple
oui mais l'union civile il faut en faire
votre deuil l'article premier a été
adopté l'article que ce soit douloureux
je veux encenir et même compatir si
nécessaire mais la le le l'assemblée des
sénateurs a adopté l'article 1er du
projet de loi monsieur le sénateur ben
oui monsieur le sénateur le noir donc
vous dit mais c'est notre Code civil qui
est ainsi fait et c'est toute l'histoire
de l'écriture de ce code civil le
mariage emporte
l'adoption le fait d'être marié ouvre le
droit à l'adoption pour les couples
hétérosexuel et pour les couples
homosexuel ah vous dites pourquoi on ser
on se s'est pas arrêté mais parce que si
on est arrêté la préoccupation que vous
exprimez avec insistance monsieur le
sénateur revet et vous a
raison j'ai entendu la question j'ai
entendu la question puisquelle a été
posée et reposée euh malgré les réponses
mais je vais vous répondre si vous
permettez si vous permettez ça ne va pas
vous empêcher de la reposer mais je je
je vous répondrai à nouveau je vous
répondrai à nouveau donc par rapport à
vos préoccupations mais c'est là que la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
pourrait être fondé à prendre une
décision contre la France en disant que
vous ouvrez l'institution du mariage
mais vous amputez cette ouverture d'une
conséquence du mariage qui est inscrite
dans votre droit à
vous et vous faites donc une
discrimination entre les couples
hétérosexuels et les couples homosexuels
donc cette proposition que vous faites
c'est elle qui pourrait tomber sous la
censure de la Cour européenne des droits
de l'homme vous nous interrogez sur la
PMA et la GPA sur la CP partiellement
partiellement je n'ai pas terminé il y
aurait un risque si nous si nous
obtempériions à vos suggestions présenté
avec oui itération monsieur le le
sénateur euh leenoir absolument oui si
si nous obtempérions alors je n'ai
répondu que partiellement parce que
votre question mérite que nous allions
plus loin puisque vous demandez quelles
seraient les conséquences si
effectivement la Cour européenne était
saisie et est-ce qu'elle ne nous
contraindrait pas à euh ouvrir la PMA et
la GPA d'abord une première réponse
presque factuelle que je vous ferai
nous ne sommes pas le premier pays
européen à ouvrir le mariage au couple
de même
sexe que je sache ni l'Espagne ni les
Pays-Bas ni le Portugal non n'ont été
peu importe la question et de savoir si
à partir du moment où les couples de
même sexe sont autorisés à se marier
est-ce que la Cour européenne peut
imposer la PMA et la GPA c'est ça la
question madame desego queles que soient
les différences de législation et ben je
répète que ça serait déjà arrivé ça
serait déjà arrivé à l'Espagne au
Portugal et ben il se trouve que ça
n'est pas arrivé et ça n'est pas arrivé
pour une raison toute simple pour une
raison toute simple c'est que que l'on
regarde le le ce que nous avons vu
récemment sur les interpellations faites
par le doy g à savoir les engagements de
la France à travers les conventions
bilatérales et multilatérales et euh les
risques éventuel j'ai rappelé la
décision récente de la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme qui date de 2010
et qui dit très clairement que ces
questions relèvent des législations et
des autorités nationales et s'il y avait
un risque vous pensez bien que les
contestations fortes aussi dans un
certain nombre de pays européens le
dernier pays enfin l'avantdernier pays a
été l'Espagne vous vous souvenez des
contestations exprimées fortement y
compris dans la rue en Espagne vous
savez qu'il y a une saisine de la Cour
constitutionnelle équivalent la Cour
suprême d'Espagne vous savez qu'il y a
une saisine vous savez qu'il y a une
décision qui a qui a longuement mûri la
saisine N a eu en 2005 la décision est
intervenue en 2012 récemment fin 2012 et
vous avez bien vu que la décision de la
Cour suprême espagnole a été que cette
disposition était tout à fait conforme à
la Constitution espagnole mais vous
pensez bien que ceux qui ont saisi la
Cour suprême espagnole auraient saisi la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
s'il pensaiit que cette saisine avait
des chances de prospérer 7 ans plus tard
ils ne l'ont pas fait pourquoi vous
voulez imaginer mais simplement parce
que il est évident que aussi bien le
droit que la jurisprudence démontre très
clairement que la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme n'a aucun fondement
juridique pour imposer l'ouverture de la
PMA les pays le font s'il le souhaitent
les pays le font s'il le souhaitent je
le texte sur lequel nous travaillons
concerne l'ouverture du mariage et de
l'adoption au couple de même sexe sur la
PMA sur la PMA la ministre de la Famille
vous a répondu j'allais presque dire
comme les enfants de collège parce que
il y a parfois cette ambiance elle vous
a répondu 512 fois que sur la PMA elle
est chargée d'un projet de loi sur la
famille sur
lesffiliation et que cette question sera
traitée alors l'un d'entre vous je crois
que c'est vous monsieur le sénateur
revet vous avez dit mais pourquoi vous
n'z pas tenu compte je suis pas sûr que
soit vous d'ailleurs du du quand je fini
ma phrase vous saurez de laave du
conseil consultatif national d'éthique
mais n rien à voir dans ça sommes sur le
Code civil ah vous avez raison de
contester ça n'est pas vous ça vous
ressemble pas donc pourquoi pourquoi
qu'est-ce que le
Conseil national consultatif d'éthique
vient faire dans l'état des personnes là
voilà nous sommes sur le Code civil nous
sommes sur l'état des personnes donc le
gouvernement n'av aucune raison de se
préoccuper ni de saisir et d'ailleurs le
Conseil lui-même ne s'est pas autosaisi
du sujet par contre il s'est autosaisi
du sujet PMA parce que dans notre droit
actuel la PMA et en fait la M parce que
dans notre droit ce qui existe c'est
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
il est dans le code de la santé publique
parce que c'est une assistance qui est
apportée à la procréation au cou couple
hétérosexuel marié ou non ça n'est pas
un sujet lié au
mariage donc il n'y a aucune raison de
nous faire valoir ni que il faut
absolument débattre de la PMA ni que
l'Union européenne ou ou le Conseil de
l'Europe nous imposera donc en
l'occurrence la CEDH nous nous imposera
la PMA ni que le sujet est absolument
lié qu'il est inévitable et cetera la
meilleure preuve qui n'est pas
inévitable les pays les pays peuvent
s'en saisir les gouvernement on le droit
s' sais saisir sans saisir le le sujet
n'est pas inévitable la meilleure preuve
je voulais indiquer lors de ma première
intervention à la tribune c'est que
regardons autour de nous les pays qui
ont ouvert le mariage et l'adoption avec
la fin de la phrase c'est pas partout la
même chose j'en conviens donc on met un
astérisque pour que ça se répète tout
seul donc les pays qui ont ouvert le
mariage n'ont pas tous ouvert la PMA ils
n'ont pas tous ouvert ceux qui ont
ouvert le mariage et la PMA l'ont fait
dans deux textes de loi
différents certains la plupart
d'ailleurs euh un un texte bioéthique et
les Pays-Bas par exemple l'a fait dans
un texte d'égalité de traitement Vous
avez même des pays qui ont ouvert la PMA
au couple de femmes homosexuelles et aux
femmes célibataires et qui n'ont pas
ouvert le mariage au coupes de même sexe
c'est bien l'illustration que ce sont
deux sujets qui se traitent séparément
et consenter enfin que nous avancions
dans les débats en traitant séparément
de la question la PMA le Premier
ministre s'est clairement exprimé il a
dit la PMA fera l'objet d'un texte sur
la famille et les modes de filiation le
gouvernement choisit d'attendre le
rapport du Conseil consultatif national
d'éthique qui s'est autosaisi ce conseil
a prévenu que son serait disponible au
dernier trimestre 2013 probablement au
début du dernier trimestre donc en
octobre et le gouvernement avisera à ce
moment-là voilà mais poursuivant nos
débats sur le texte qui nous est soumis
euh vous avez euh monsieur noirg
monsieur le sénateur Bordier qui évoque
la circulaire euh qui selon ses propos
attribue la nationalité française et
fait quoi procède à la
transcription d'enfants nés de
GPA je me dois à ce moment de vous faire
de vous apporter une information qui a
pu vous échapper encore que j'ai eu à
l'expliquer 11 fois exactement à
l'Assemblée nationale parce que c'est
ainsi que se déroule ces débats plus
nous répondons et plus la question
revient qu'est-ce j'y compte bien
j'espère et je pense que vous avez ici
quelques ce qu'on appelle un peu
trivialement des leaders d'opinion qui
veilleront qui veilleront à ce que vous
ne vous livriez pas à ce type d'exercice
euh la ciaculaire la circulaire elle dit
quoi elle s'adresse à qui d'abord elle
s'adresse évidemment au parquets
généraux et pour attribution au parquet
pour information et au greffier pour
exécution parce que en ma qualité de
garde des saut c'est à eux que je peux
m'adresser et elle leur dit quoi elle
demande que les greffiers ne fassent pas
opposition à
l'attribution à la délivrance en clair à
la délivrance du certificat de
nationalité pour des enfants sur
lesquels ils auraient un doute en se
demandant si ces enfants ne seraiitpané
de GPA quelle est la situation réelle la
situation c'est que des enfants les
enfants obtiennent la nationalité par
filiation c'est notre Code civil ils
obtiennent la nationalité par
affiliation des enfants naissent à
l'étranger des enfants français naissent
à l'étranger des couples français des
familles françaises font des enfants à
l'étranger que se passe-t-il il
s'adresse à nos consulats qui enregistre
l'état civil de ses enfant et
transmettre de façon à ce que cet état
civil soit transcrit dans notre registre
national d'état civil nous sommes
d'accord il y a des dizaines de milliers
d'enregistrements de naissance d'enfants
français à l'étranger
et puis dans nos consulats il arrive
qu'il y a un doute et qu'au moment de
l'enregistrement le consulat se demande
si cet enfant ne serait pas né de GPA
consciencieusement il alerte n'est-ce
pas monsieur le garde des saau vous le
savez et vous avez fait sortir également
pour 2011 le nombre d'enfants qui
étaient concernés donc notre consulat
alerte en disant attention nous avons
l'impression il y a quand même une
présomption une suspicion des des des
signes qui nous permettent de penser que
peut-être cet enfant est né de
GPA mais que se passe-t-il pour la
nationalité de cet enfant si ses parents
sont français et s'il est établi que ce
sont bien les enfants de ses parents là
les enfants obtiennent la nationalité du
fait de notre Code civil mais ça
n'évacue pas le doute du consulat et le
consulat donc transmet
au au au service de Nant qui lui saisit
le parquet de Nantes qui examine les cas
combien de cas avons-nous eu sur entre
2008 et 2011 44 cas
exactement et en
2012 ah oui c'est une coïncidence qui
m'avait échappé monsieur le sénateur
nous allons finir tous superstitieux
après ce
débat sur l'année 12 il y en a eu 11
exactement c'est-à-dire une moyenne qui
se tient d'année en année que s'est-il
passé il s'est passé évidemment que le
procureur de la République s'est
prononcé sur ces cas et dans la plupart
des cas il a confirmé le doute il a
confirmé le doute et donc il a dit pour
2012 par exemple sur 11 cas il y avait
confirmations oui il y a quand même il a
confirmé le doute confirme pas une
certitude il confirme le doute oui il y
a probablement la ugpa que se passe-t-il
l'enfant puisque il est établi que c'est
bien l'enfant de ces parentsl l'enfant a
la nationalité
française il l'a s'agit pas de la lui
attribuer il l'a donc à partir de ce
moment-là il se retrouve devant des
tribunaux qui lui délivre son certificat
de nationalité française la nationalité
existe et puis il arrive que il soit
confronté à un grve de tribunal qui dit
moi aussi j'ai un doute je ne donne pas
le certificat cas de nationalité sauf
que la nationalité est établie c'est
comme si vous aviez passé le
baccalauréat c'est l'exemple que j'avais
pris aussi à l'Assemblée national c'est
comme si on a passé le baccalauréat et
quand on va demander la délivrance du
diplôme le le le le le le fonctionnaire
auquel on s'adresse dire moi je suis pas
viux que vous n'z pas triché quoi au
baccalauréat bon sauf que vous présentez
la preuve que vous avez obtenu le
baccalauréat si vous avez triché c'est
une autre procédure mais puisque vous
présentez la preuve que vous avez réussi
que vous êtes reconnu officiellement
comme ayant réussi au baccalauréat on
doit vous délivrer éventuellement on
engage une autre action au justice mais
on ne peut pas contester votre droit à
disposer de ce certificat de nationalité
voilà ce que fait ma
circulaire voilà ce que fait simplement
cette circulaire de janvier elle
interpelle les greffiers pour leur dire
la nationalité française étant établie
pour ses enfants vous n'avez pas de
fondement juridique qui vous autorise à
ne pas délivrer ce certificat de
nationalité française et toutes ces
dernières années que s'est-il passé le
gouvernement votre les gouvernements
vous avez soutenu ont fait la même chose
ont fait la même chose ils n'ont pas
fait de circulaire ils n'ont pas osé ils
ont eu tort ça aurait été à leur
crédit
il ah pardon monsieur le garde des saau
ce n'est pas à vous que je vais dire que
l'indépendance de la justice n'interdit
pas palais circulaire bien au contraire
plus la justice sera indépendante plus
l'exécutif sera responsable de la
politique pénale et des politiques
publicque de justice sur le territoire
plus il faudra des circulaires
impersonnels et générales donc ce
gouvernement pendant 5 ans il a fait la
même chose c'est-à-dire que il a admis
que la nationalité étant établie les
certificats de nationalité devait être
délivré il y a un autre sujet avec la
transcription dans le registre d' civile
en cas de doute et justement pour ces 44
enfants des années 2008 à 2011 plus les
11 de l'année 2012 il y a un problème de
transcription dans l'état civil ils ont
la nationalité française ils ont donc le
droit d'avoir leur certificat de
nationalité par contre est-ce que nous
transcrivons mais puisque la justice dit
il y a doute sur la DGPA nous ne
transcrivons pas et la circulaire ne
donne pas consigne de transcrire dans
l'état civil d'ailleurs parce que la
circulaire s'adresse au greffier et que
la transcription dans l'état civil sont
pas les greffiers quiil font donc on
peut pas dire que cette circulaire
demande la transcription dans l'état
civil puisqueelle ne s'adresse pas aux
personnes qui sont chargées de la
transcription de l'état civil cependant
nous ne pouvons pas nous en contenter
vous qui parlez sans arrêt de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant vous qui avez le
souci de l'enfant mais des enfants réels
là physiquees de chair hein hein
contrariant agaçant désobéissant câlin
sympathique adoraable insupportable ces
enfants-là c'est deux que nous parlons
d'accord bon alors ces enfantsl nous
avons quand même le souci de leur avenir
ils ont leur certificat de nationalité
et la circulaire dit bien puisqu'ils y
ont droit il faut le leur donner mais
ils ne sont pas transcrits au registre
d'état civil ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire parce que je rappelle quand même
que cette nationalité française elle
ouvre tous les
effets de droit lié à la nationalité et
à l'affiliation autrement dit il n'y a
aucun problème pour ces enfants pour
être inscrit à l'école pour leurs
parents pour percevoir les allocations
familiales pour l'autorité parentale
pour les droits successoraux il n'y a
pas de problème c'est déduit de
l'affiliation par contre effectivement
comme ils ne sont pas inscrits sur le
registre d'état civil chaque fois qu'ils
ont besoin d'une pièce d'état civil il
faut revenir au consulat c'est-à-dire là
où ils ont été enregistré donc c'est une
difficulté c'est une
complication la question que nous nous
posons et là j'ai mis en place un groupe
pour y réfléchir la question que nous
posons c'est de savoir par exemple à
leur majorité comment nous faisons en
sorte que ces enfants entrent dans
l'état civil français puisqu'ils sont
français convenez quand même que c'est
un acte de justice bon voilà mais c'est
de ça qui s'agit donc j'espère avoir
éteint ici le le procès sur à la fois
l'attribution de nationalité d'enfants
GD GPA de transcription indument dans
l'état civil et cetera j'espère avoir
éint le procès je n'en suis pas persuadé
je ne serai pas autrement surprise si
des interventions revenaient sur ce
sujet mais j'y répondrai à nouveau de
bonnes
grâces
sur monsieur
reto
merci
merci merci à
vous je n'ai pas fini mais je reconnais
que c'est extrêmement
chaleureux
mer merci
beaucoup je n'ai pas je nai pas fini
mais c'est un geste que je reçois euh
avec beaucoup de chaleur et beaucoup de
gratitude de la part des sénateurs
qui pensent comme vous qu'il est
important que le Sénat puisse travailler
sur les questions économiques et
sociales que les sénateurs puissent être
mobiliser sur les sénatrices et
sénateurs puissent
être non surtout que quand je regarde
par là quand je regarde par là ça me
saute aux yeux madame des
ég sa aux
yeux madame la garde des saau madame oui
madame madame la sénatrice des éego vous
cherchez querelle inutilement parce que
il y a une formule il y a une formule
que j'utilise systématiquement c'est
mesdames les sénatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs bon donc oui
mais oui donc je je je dis que toute ma
gratitude parce que je sais à quel point
vous avez travaillé sérieusement pour la
préparation de ce texte de loi je sais
le temps et l'énergie que vous y avez
consacré et je sais à quel point souvent
souvent depuis le début de nos débats
vous avez envie
d'intervenir vous souhaiteriez répondre
vous souhaiteriez argumenter et je sais
que vous le feriez
brillamment je sais le sacrifice auquel
vous consentez en ne prenant pas la
parole donc je vous dis toute ma
gratitude de céder ainsi le temps de
parole à l'opposition et de faire en
sorte que nous
avancions que nous avancions pour que
vous puissiez vous consacrer le
gouvernement aussi à d'autres questions
et c'est pour ça que je vous dis ma
reconnaissance
personnelle je vais je vais terminer
avec quelques observations de la part de
monsieur le sénateur rillot et en
particulier
sur la l'incompétence négative que vous
avez évoqué vous avez il me semble
indiquer que le texte ne modifiait pas
les articles 57 et 354 du Code civil si
vous ne l'avez pas indiqué je suppose
vous n'avez pas indiqué en particulier
mais en tout cas c'est c'est un fait que
le texte n'y touche pas et vous avez
évoqué l'incompétence négative pour dire
que le
législateur devrait aller jusqu'au bout
c'est le principe de l'incompétence
négative aller jusqu'au bout de sa
responsabilité et par conséquent aller
jusqu'à l'élaboration de l'état civil
nous sommes d'accord c'est
clair alors je vous réponds dessus si
c'est pas ça je vous fais confiance même
si c'est ça je vous fais confiance pour
revenir et reposer la question
donc je vous apporte ces éléments de
réponse vous avez raison que le en tout
cas si vous l'avez pas dit j'indique que
le texte ne touche pas aux articles 57
et 354 pour éclairer l'assemblée indiqué
que ce sont des articles qui précisent
le les les éléments qui sont contenus
dans les déclarations d'état civil donc
les actes de naissance les actes d'état
civil euh simplement je vous rappelle
que le législateur est chargé des règles
il n'est pas chargé du format il n'est
pas chargé de la présentation il est
chargé des règles sur l'état civil et
ces règles elles sont élaborées elles
relèvent bien du droit elles relèvent
bien du Code civil et c'est délibérément
que ni l'assemblée ni la commission des
lois n'ont touché à ces articles 57 et
354 et la meilleure preuve la meilleure
illustration que la responsabilité du
législateur concerne les règles et non
pas la présentation et le format c'est
que ces autres questions là présentation
et format sont réglé par la circulaire
générale à l'état civ cile qui
d'ailleurs a été modifié sous votre
responsabilité en octobre 2011 la
dernière fois hein c'est la plus récente
et par conséquent là il n'y a pas
conflit d'in compétence négative de la
part de législateur le législateur va
jusqu'où il doit aller en l'occurrence
et il ne va pas au-delà c'est-à-dire
queil ne va pas empiéter inutilement sur
la responsabilité réglementaire qui en
l'occurrence c'est plus une
responsabilité qu'un pouvoir et il a
raison il a raison il est déjà arrivé
que le législateur piétine volontiers le
pouvoir réglementaire il nous est arrivé
en qualité de parlementaire de grignoter
sur le pouvoir réglementaire je l'ai
fait moi-même en tant que parlementaire
donc oui mais toujours en argumentant
toujours en expliquant la nécessité
d'aller aussi loin parce que parce que
il y a une inertie parce que il y a
parfois une mauvaise volonté de la part
de l'exécutif qui fait que le
législateur pour être sûr de
l'aboutissement de son travail il va un
peu au-delà de son propre périmètre par
contre vous évoquez les les ordonnances
pour expliquer pourquoi et comment le
législateur justement se met en
situation d'incompétenence négative non
monsieur le sénateur illo parce que les
ordonnances telles qu'elles sont prévues
dans le texte qui nous est soumis ne
concerne pas du tout ces règles-là
c'est il s'agit je vous le rappelle du
choix fait par la commission des lois de
remplacer c'est la disposition
interprétative qui avait été introduite
par l'Assemblée nationale par une
disposition VO qu'on appelle
trivialement article balai par une
disposition générale qui dispose que euh
les les les effets et les obligations de
droit sont les mêmes que les époux
ou parents soit de sexe différents ou de
même sexe voilà c'est une disposition
générale la commission des lois a
souhaité laadosser à une habilitation
donnée au gouvernement pour prendre par
ordonnance des dispositions dans les 6
mois non pas sur les règles monsieur le
sénateur retaillot mais pour la
coordination pour la coordination
puisque vous vous rappelez que dans le
projet de loi la première forme
d'écriture qui avait été choisie par le
gouvernement consistait à procéder de
façon exhaustive à toutes les
coordinations nécessaires dans le Code
civil et dans les autres e lois et
ordonnances l'assemblée a fait un autre
choix votre commission de lois a fait un
troisième choix de disposition générale
qui la doosse à une habilitation
accordée au gouvernement de faire dans
les 6 mois toutes les coordinations
nécessaires donc nous ne sommes pas dans
une situation d'incompétences négatives
je suis au regret de ne pas avoir de
citation pour madame desego je suis je
suis navré que les citations vous
déplaise à ce point-là mais pardon elles
me font un peu plaisir c'est égoïste en
général ell font F plaisir à ceux qui
les entendent je n'ai aucun mérite parce
que ce sont de très très grands auteurs
qui ont écrit les citations que je
partage très volontiers avec vous je
vous en prise pour cette fois-là je vous
en ferai je vous en ferai cadeau lors
d'une prochaine
intervention merci
oui monsieur le sénateur hon
pour une précision
oui mesdames les ministres monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues simplement
effectivement une précision relative à
une rectification de vote puisque bien
qu'étant présent en séance hier soir au
moment du vote non il ne dormait pas il
y a pas de souci sur l'article 1 donc le
scrutin
148 il m'a été donné de vérifier
aujourd'hui qu'une erreur avait été
commise je me suis depuis le début
opposé au projet de loi bien sûr et à
cet article donc je souhaite qu'il soit
procédé rectification j'espère que vous
n'en serez pas navré mesdames et
messieurs de la majorité en solidarité
depuis le début avec mes collègu sur
l'autre partie de l'hémicycle si acte
vous est donné monsieur le sénateur de
votre mise au point qui sera publié au
Journal officiel et figurera dans
l'analyse politique du scrutin nous en
venons donc sur l'article 1er bis à
l'amendement 174 actifié TER présenté
par Monsieur
soqueto par Madame F monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues voici venu le moment de
confirmer nos positions en l'état actuel
du droit le Code civil permet l'adoption
pliniiaère de l'enfant du conjoint dans
trois cas lorsque l'enfant n'a de
filiation légalement établies qu'à
l'égard de ce conjoint lorsque l'autre
parent que le conjoint s'est vu retirer
totalement l'autorité parentale enfin
lorsque l'autre parent que le conjoint
est décédé et n'a pas laissé d'ascendant
au premier degré ou lorsque ceuxci se
sont manifestement désintéressés de
l'enfant l'article 1ier bis du texte
vise à permettre l'adoption plinière de
l'enfant du conjoint dans un 4e cas
lorsque l'enfant a déjà fait l'objet
d'une adoption pliniiaire par ce seul
conjoint les dispositions de l'article
1er bis sont liées à l'ouverture de
l'adoption au couple de personnes de
même sexe cet article nous est présenté
comme une simple précision pour éviter
des interprétations divergentes de la
loi or s'il peut également s'appliquer
au couple composé d'un homme et d'une
femme l'article 1er anticipe en réalité
l'ouverture de l'adoption au couple de
personnes de même sexe il vise donc à
permettre l'adoption non simultanée par
un couple homosexuel marié et ainsi de
faire de l'adoption
intrafamiliale le moyen privilégié pour
établir un lien de filiation entre un
enfant et deux adultes du même sexe nous
sommes donc opposés à l'ouverture de
l'adoption au couple homosexuel et
proposons donc la suppression de cet
article premier
bis alors nous nous passons donc à
l'amendement 210 rectifié monsieur
milidon oui merci monsieur le Président
euh les les motivations pour présenter
cet amendement de de suppression de
l'article 1 bis en ce qui me concerne et
en ce qui concerne le cignataire
monsieur printon ne sont pas les mêmes
que les motivations présentées par
Monsieur zooketo ou par la sénatrice qui
a présenté l'amendement c'est ve dire
que nous considérons que l'adoption et
en particulier l'adoption plénire ne
peut pas être faite par un couple
homosexuel et que ça entraînerait une
séparation nette dans l'affiliation
sachant que l'adoption pléniaire
entraîne la suppression complète de des
origines et d'affiliation normale
naturelle qui est un père et une mère et
nous préférons et les amendements que je
présenterai par la suite nous préférons
mettre en place une adoption simple qui
elle n'entraîne pas de suppression de
filiation génétique oserais-je dire et
qui permettrait au contraire à l'enfant
de ne pas avoir la suppression complète
de ses origines alors c'est cela étant
dit j'aimerais si vous me le permettez
revenir deux ou 3 secondes sur des
textes qui ont été émis par mes
collègues pour leur dire que la GPA
n'existe pas en France mais que la PMA
existe qu'elle est faite tous les jours
qu'elle est faite tous les jours pour
des couples stériles ou pour des couples
non fertiles et que je voudrais que vous
ne disiez plus je souhaiterais que vous
ne disiez plus que vous êtes contre la
PMA mais qu'à la rigueur bien qu' ne
partant pas ce que vous dites que vous
soyez contre la PMA de convenance
merci bien merci sur ces amendements
quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur euh la commission
monsieur le Président mesam les
ministres est opposé à ces amendements
qui ne sont pas de même mais bon en fait
dans la loi aucun article ne parle de
l'adoption plinière puisque l'ouverture
du mariage prévoit IPS facto l'adoption
plinière par les couples mariés donc
dans cet article simplement qu'est-ce
que nous disons nous apportons une
précision que d'ailleurs monsieur
soqueto à la convenu en commission des
lois cette précision c'est que nous
interdisions l'adoption sans l'adoption
voilà un enfant ne peut avoir que deux
parents adoptifs point final voilà ce
que veut dire cet article alors vous
vous y opposez parce que comme vous êtes
hostile à l'adoption plinière ben Vous
vous opposez à la précision qu'on peut
apporter là mais c'est la précision
qu'on apporte et donc n sommes
défavorable également à l'amendement de
monsieur mon qui est le même pour des
raisons différentes puisque monsieur mon
si j'ai bien compris est défavorable à
l'adoption plinière mais ne serait
favorable qu'à l'adoption simple nous
parlerons de l'adoption simple dans
l'article suivant donc avis défavorable
si avis du gouvernement madame le
gardessau oui monsieur le Président la
vie du du gouvernement messieurs les
sénateurs puisque vous êtes plusieurs
signataires est défavorable sur cet
amendement en fait bon rappelez euh
peut-être mais je crois pas que ce soit
utile parce que les débats j'ai lu les
auditions j'ai lu euh vos débats en plus
d'avoir été auditionné moi-même je crois
que tout le monde ici c'est ce qui'est
l'adoption pliniiaère ce qui est
l'adoption simple et surtout les
conséquences de chacun donc l'Assemblée
nationale avait introduit des
modifications euh que la commission des
lois a corrigé et par conséquent on peut
considérer le souci de la commission des
lois c'était d'éviter une pluri
parentalité
euh considérons que la les modifications
introduites par la commission des lois
euh éliminent euh ce risque de
pluriparentalité euh en rappelant
simplement que l'adoption pliniiaire
pose le sujet dans la mesure où euh le
le il y a euh à l'adoption pliniiaire il
y a euh je sais pas comment dire parce
que je trouve tellement agressif le fait
qu'on supprime on élimine on gomme on
efface euh l'affiliation qui précédait
par contre l'adoption simple se pose sur
l'affiliation qui existait donc l' viis
est défavorable de la suppression de
cette disposition merci alors une
explication de vote sur ces deux
amendements madame Marie-Thérèse
Bruguier
en ce qui con monsieur le président
madame la garde des saau madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur en ce
qui concerne l'adoption de loi cetteette
loi qui va créer des inégalités entre
les enfants entre ceux qui ne seront pas
adoptables d'autres le seront par
adoption simple d'autres encore par
adoption plainiaire à l'état actuel du
droit le Code civil permet l'adoption
pliniiaire de l'enfant du conjoint dans
trois cas lorsque l'enfant n'a de
filiation légalement établie qu'à
l'égard de ce conjoint lorsque l'autre
parent que le conjoint s'est vu retirer
totalement l'autorité parentale enfin
lorsque l'autre parent que le conjoint
est décédé et n'a pas laissé d'ascendant
au premier degré ou lorsque ceux-ci se
sont manifestement désintéressés de
l'enfant l'article 1er vise à permettre
l'adoption plainiaire de l'enfant du
conjoint dans un 4e cas lorsque l'enfant
a déjà fait l'objet d'une adoption
pliniiaèire par ce seul conjoint si cet
article nous est présenté comme une
simple précision pour éviter des
interprétations divergentes de la loi en
fait il souhait rendre possibles des
adoptions intrafamiliales au sein de
famille au mot parental dans lesquelles
l'affiliation des enfants n'est établie
par la voix de de
l'adoption qu'à l'égard de l'un des deux
parents il anticipe en réalité
l'ouverture d'adoption au couple de
personnes de même sexe nous y sommes
donc opposé à l'état actuel du droit
mieux vaut régler des situation ces
situations dans une loi future sur la
famille et plus particulièrement sur
l'adoption merci monsieur le Président
merci la parole à Monsieur
Savari bien monsieur le président madame
la garde des saau madame le ministre je
voudrais simplement et pour répondre
notamment à Madame le Ministre de la
Famille amener le témoin que les
présidents des président de conseils
généraux et notamment du en tant que
président du conseil général de la Marne
témoignage que connaissent bien nombreux
des collègues vous savez nous avons à
gérer les difficultés des enfants les
compétences de l'enfance et de la
famille sont véritablement dévolués au
département et nous savons combien nous
essayons de mener ces missions avec la
compétence bien sûr de nos travailleurs
sociaux mais également le côté humain
tout à fait nécessaire traitement de ces
difficultés on voit bien l'ensemble des
difficultés des familles dstructurées
que nous rencontrons et que les
travailleurs sociaux nous remonte vous
savez que nous avons la responsabilité
également de toutora pour les enfants
qui sont enlevés des famill en ce qui
concerne le département de la Marne ce
sont plus de 1300 enfants qui sont s ma
responsabilité c'est la raison pour
laquelle je pense que les leçons données
à travers les propos de Madame ministre
de la Famille sont parfois difficile à
entendre mais revenons au problème de
l'adoption l'adoption nous avons des
règles de droit qui s'appliquent et
c'est dans ce cadre là que nous avons
une commission comme tous les
départements qui fait un travail
particulièrement
important et je voudrais rappeler
qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'article 346 du
Code civil qui précise que nul ne peut
être adopté par plusieurs personnes si
ce ne son deux époux et en France la
législation sur l'adoption est stricte
sur les conditions d'accueil réservant
pri prioritairement pardon l'adoption à
des couples mariés engagés dans la durée
ce processus demande une solidité
particulière pour celles et ceux qui ont
à accueillir ces enfants don la
souffrance est parfois inévitable et la
force des projets parentaux madame la
ministre de la Famille est tout à fait
bien sûr décisive dans les décisions qui
sont prises l'ouverture à l'adoption
pour les coupes de msems fait croire à
un droit à l'enfant et on oublie les
droits de l'enfant et je considère comme
beaucoup je suis sûr comme l'ensemble de
mes collègues ici présents que l'enfant
est considéré comme un don et non comme
un D l'adoption doit donc rester un
droit de l'enfant et non un droit des
adultes alors vous avez évoqué les
chiffres sur le plan
national et je voudrais si vous me
permettez évoquer décliner sur le plan
local les chiffres du nombre d'agréments
et du nombre d'enfants adoptés en ce qui
concerne le département de la Marne de
taille moyenne entre 2008 et 2012 il y a
eu en moyenne
48,6 demande d'agrément dont 37,2 par an
fait par des couples et 4 fait par une
personne seule vivant en couple et 7,4
en moyenne
par année formulé par une personne
célibataire mais en ce qui concerne la
réalisation de ces projets d'adoption
c'est-àdire le nombre d'enfants adoptés
et ben la moyenne est de 17,8 parents
dont 7 enfants pupill de l'État avec des
minimums de 11 parents et des maximums
de 24 tout enfants confondus et se
enfants de moyenne pupie de l'État
quatre parfois seulement dans l'année
donc il y a trois fois plus de de
demande d'agrément que d'adoption et
rappelons que les agréments tombent au
bout de 5 ans et qu'ils font beaucoup de
parents
déçus il est donc dans cette affaire là
à prendre en compte l'ensemble de ces
préoccupation et d'autant plus que
certains pays ont prévu de réduire et
parfois même de rompre les autorisations
d'adoption avec la France si ce projet
de loi était voté donc on voit bien que
le problème se pose et il faut
l'appréhender à sa juste mesure et c'est
la raison pour laquelle personnellement
je peux concevoir l'adoption simple de
l'enfant d'un conjoint mais qu'on ne
peut aller plus loin cont tenu de la
façon dont est tourné ce projet de loi
effectivement l'adoption plinièire rille
rille l'affiliation vous l'avez dit et
je pense que il y aurait une destruction
de la l'ffiliation si on allait plus
loin dans la loi qui nous ne permettrait
pas en tout cas en ce qui me concerne de
la
voter la parole à madame Isabelle
Debray merci monsieur le Président
pardon mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues cet article est très différent
de l'article précédent en effet dans
cette dans l'article précédent on
parlait de vie en couple la vie en
couple c'est une vie choisie par des
adultes là nous parlons d'adoption
l'adoption c'est une vie imposée par des
adultes à des enfants c'est une
différence
fondamentale ce que je voulais dire
Madame le Ministre tout à l'heure vous
avez dit effectivement que dans notre
pays il est possible qu'un célibataire
adopte un enfant vous avez raison dont
et effectivement lorsque ce
célibataire se met en couple avec une
personne de sexe opposé l'adoption est
possible
aujourd'hui lorsque ce célibataire se
met en couple avec un homme ou une enfin
une personne de même sexe l'adoption
plinière ou simple n'est pas possible
mais pourquoi pour moi je trouve ça
normal il est impensable à mes yeux et
vous savez que je l'enfance depuis de
nombreuses années qu'un enfant puisse
dire j'ai deux papas ou j'ai deux mamans
je vous le dis pardonnez-moi j'ai
toujours fait preuve de beaucoup de
respect quand vous parliez laissez-moi
m'expliquer si vous le voulez bien en
revanche pour moi il est tout à fait
possible qu'un enfant dise j'ai un papa
le compagnon de mon papa j'ai une maman
la compagne de ma maman je ne mets
jamais en doute la possibilité pour un
couple
homosexuel de d'élever un enfant je ne
l'ai jamais mise en doute ils apportent
effectivement sécurité ils apportent
affection ils apportent éducation là
n'est pas le problème en revanche là
vous avez raison Madame le Ministre
c'est que l'on parle des droits de
l'enfant mais je voudrais aussi parler
des devoirs des adultes c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui lorsqu'un enfant est
adopté de façon plinière par un
célibataire qu'il soit homme ou femme et
que ce célibataire se met en couple avec
une personne de même sexe si par hasard
il arrivait quelque chose à l'adoptant
l'enfant se retrouve trouve des facto
orphelin et ça ça n'est pas possible il
faut donner bien sûr des droits à cet
enfant mais il faut donner aussi des
devoirs à la personne qui leur a élevé
pendant toutes ces années il est
impensable que que le conjoint ou la
conjointe du parent adoptant ne puisse
avoir continuer des devoirs vis-à-vis de
l'enfant et que l'enfant ne puisse pas
avoir des droits effectivement à
l'affection à la suite de l'éducation et
c'est pour cela qu'aujourd'hui
l'adoption simple répond parfaitement à
cette à cette problématique et c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui il est
inconcevable de d'immédiatement
légiférer comme ça nous pourrions tout à
fait attendre comme le le propose le
proposera le doyen Géard la loi sur la
famille ou alors supprimer maintenant ou
alors l'adoption simple mais l'adoption
pliniiaire pour moi n'est pas possible
je voudrais aussi soulever un autre
problème qui est un problème d'égalité
vous nous parlez d'égalité depuis le
début de de cette de l'examen de cette
loi mais elle est où l'égalité 2 ans
enfants qui sont dans une famille
d'accueil l'un va être accueilli dans
une famille homosexuelle l'autre dans
une famille hétérosexuelle encore une
fois je ne remets jamais en doute la
possibilité que ces enfants reçoivent
une éducation parfaite des deux côtés là
n'est pas le problème mais il y a un
problème de repère il y a un problème de
repère et aujourd'hui on connaît des
enfants élevés par des couples
homosexuels qui sont effectivement
parfaitement bien élevé mais le repère
n'est pas le même le repère les enfants
ont besoin de savoir qu'ils ont été
conçu jusqu'à nouvel ordre par un homme
et par une femme il est donc pour moi
inconcevable que deux personnes puissent
se dire père et que deux personnes
puissent se dire maire c'est pour cela
que je suis opposée à l'adoption
plainiare des deux personnes je vous
remercie merci la parole à Monsieur
Philippe
B merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres chers collègues tout
d'abord je veux bien sûr euh partager
l'interprétation juridique tout à fait
cohérente qui a été celle de madame la
garde des saau tout à l'heure je crois
en effet que quand on rentre dans le
régime du mariage il faut le dérouler
jusqu'au bout il n'est pas possible
d'avoir à la fois le mariage et la non
adoption car l'adoption par le conjoint
c'est un des éléments du régime du
mariage et c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle est tant en désaccord avec
la possibilité de l' adoption par les
couples de même sexe j'étais également
en désaccord avec le mariage nous avons
chacun nos cohérences mais au moins nous
pouvons partager une interprétation du
droit qui me paraît tout à fait exact je
me différencie néanmoins de vous sur
l'appréciation que vous
faites des chances ou des risques je
fais droit à des
différences d'approche
sur la manière de qualifier cette
probabilité que la Cour européenne de
sauvegarde des droits de l'homme nous
force à aller plus loin en matière
d'assistance médicale à la procréation
si nous rentrons dans le régime du
mariage et ça pour une pour une raison
très simple c'est que nous aurons avec
ce système poser dans la loi le principe
d'une équivalence absolue
de la
parenté au sein des couples de même sexe
et de la parenté au sein des couples
composé de personnes de sexe
différents la notion même de parenté
évolue on ne s'arrête plus au fait qu'il
y a
outre le mariage le lien du sang pour
résumer d'ailleurs les choses avec une
expression qui est bien dans le dans le
Code civil et on dit la parenté ça n'est
pas ça ça va au-delà de ça et c'est la
raison pour laquelle lappenté dans le
Code civil tel qu'il résulterait de ce
texte ne sera pas différente pour des
couples de même sexe et des couples de
sexe différents mais si la parenté n'est
pas différente pourquoi dans un cas
supposerait-elle qu'il y ait un acte
juridique pour la reconnaître à savoir
un jugement d'adoption pour adopter
l'enfant de son épouse et être une
deuxième mère et dans un autre cas le
couple composé de personnes de sexe
différent par l'application de la
présomption de de paternité un
automatisme moi je pense que il y aura
des revendications elles auront une
cohérence et la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme justement parce
qu'elle nous dit si vous êtes rentré
dans le cadre du mariage il faut aller
jusqu'au bout nous dira par essence la
parentée étant la même dans les deux
type de couple il faudra nécessairement
que la manière de reconnaître cette
parenté soit aussi la même euh j'ajoute
que dès maintenant sans qu'il soit
besoin de se poser la question de savoir
si on peut recourir à l'insémination
artificielle en France ou pas il y aura
de très nombreux enfants parce que c'est
le moyen qui est utilisé déjà qui
naîtront dans les au sein de coupes de
femmes d'une insémination à l'étranger
et l'adoption automatique euh par le
conjoint par un jugement d'adoption et
permettra d'établir la parenté de
l'épouse de la mère à l'égard de
l'enfant mais je crois que c'est une
évidence elle est portée dans le texte
on ne peut pas le nier on peut dire je
suis pour je l'assume mais on ne peut
pas dire que ça n'est pas le cas la
question de l'assistance médicale à la
procréation est traitée certes
implicitement mais nécessairement du
point de vue juridique par le texte tel
qu'il est écrit et sur ce point madame
laarde des saau dans l'intérêt même de
l'interprétation qui sera donnée à votre
texte s'il est adopté je crois que il
serait tout à fait judicieux que vous
nous le disiez que vous le reconnaissiez
que vous le proclamiez que vous assumiez
votre position l'assistance médicale à
la procréation aura des effets de droit
dans la mesure elle permettra un
jugement d'adoption pour l'épouse de la
mère c'est très simple c'est très clair
et c'est inscrit dans la logique
juridique de votre texte alors maintenan
nous sommes sur un amendement de
suppression d'un article introduit par
l'Assemblée nationale et dont je dois
dire qu'il a été nettement amélioré par
le travail de la communission je veux en
rendre hommage à notre rapporteur parce
que en effet si laaffiliation était
établie à l'égard d'un tiers permettre
une deuxième adoption ce serait là pour
le coup tout à fait insupportable ça
engagerait les droits d'un tiers et donc
on ne pourrait pas y souscrire mais nous
ne pouvons pas non plus souscrire à
cette disposition que vous avez
introduite parce que Madame bertinoti
nous le disait à l'instant la commission
des lois le demande nous aurons un texte
sur l'adoption or comme je viens de le
rappeler les dispositions en matière
d'adoption du Code civil actuel
s'appliquent déjà au couple de qui
seront formés aux époux de même sexe qui
seront formés en application de cette
loi et donc vous introduisez une sorte
de cavalier qui relève de la loi sur
l'adoption que vous allez préparer comme
d'une part je me refuse à toute
extension du texte actuel qui élargirait
les possibilités d'adoption par les
couples de même sexe que d'autres part
le support pour prendre une telle
disposition qui n'est pas rendu
nécessaire par votre texte devrait être
choisi pour le texte que Madame
Bertinotti est en train de préparer il
me il me paraît vraiment tout à fait
nécessaire et même indispensable que le
que le Sénat ne retienne pas cette
disposition parce que légiférer
aujourd'hui sur l'adoption en général
vous voyez que cet article et
heureusement dans votre logique n'est
pas applicable au seul couple de même
sexe ben légiférer en général sur
l'adoption pour tous les couples
aujourd'hui alors qu'on nous annonce
pour dans quelques semaines un projet ou
dans quelques mois un projet ça n'a tout
simplement pas de sens monsieur Y Pozo
di
Borgo excusez-moi je mélange monsieur le
président madame la garde des saau
Madame le Ministre chers collègues j'ai
pas souvent l'occasion d'intervenir dans
ce débat mais je voudrais faire deux
remarques seminaaire avant d'intervenir
sur la suppression de cet article le
premier sénateur de Paris président d'un
groupe au Conseil de Paris je voudrais
reprendre les termes du maire Bertrand
de la noué à propos de la brutale
agression dont été victime deux
Parisiens de la nuit de samedi à
dimanche au motifs qui se tenait par la
mains bien comme le disait Bertrandon je
reprends ces termes comme disait
Bertrandon je reprends ces termes je
suis en colère et triste et cela est
inquiétant pour le mieux vivre entre
nous et cela est inqualifiable
deuxième remarque madame la garde des
saau madame la ministre vous êtes comme
moi et comme beaucoup de nos collègues
l'émanation de la génération 68 même si
vous le paraissez pas vous êtes beaucoup
plus jeune la caractéristique de cette
manif de cette génération c'est qu'elle
a été très influencé par une pensée
marxiste souvent très mal digérée à
droite comme à gauche d'ailleurs et
cette pensée marxiste avait une
caractéristique emprunté à égal
d'ailleurs c'était la dialectique
historique et C dialctique
que l'histoire va dans le sens du
progrès les 30 dernières années bien les
dernières années montr que la régr exist
en
histoire l'oire du communisme ré dans
histori pourquoi je prends cette
comparaison parce qu'on a l'impression
que la réflexion qui vous a conduit à ce
Tex du mariage pour tous est influencé
par cette pensée comme quoi
l'histoire va dans le sens du progrès et
bien moi je dis que la régression existe
aussi en histoire et notamment la
régression existe quand on bouscule trop
le naturel le naturel se vange et nous
verrons dans quelques années qui aura
raison je prends maintenant
l'intervention directement sur le texte
c'est peut-être le sens de l'histoire
qui fait madame la garde des saau que
votre obstination à vouloir coute cûe
faire adopter un texte préparant
préparer tropativement a fait que
l'article 1er bis est l'un des meilleurs
exemples des paradoxes de votre position
cet article étant le champ de l'adoption
pliniiare en permettant de faire au
conjoint d'une personne et adopté au
ayant un enfant naturel de l'adopter de
manière pliniiaèire c'est la conséquence
logique de l'article 1er le mariage
permettant adoption il s'agit dans cet
article de régler les situations
intermédiaires nées des insuffisances
antérieures cette modification
introduite à l'Assemblée nationale à
initiative du rapporteur Binet semble
cohérent dans la logique générale de
votre tte
le fait est que vous apprêtez purement
et simplement à fabriquer une machine à
frustration la convention de la de
1993 stipule que l'adoption
internationale n'est possible que
lorsque les voies nationales ont été
épuisées on sait bien qu'en France il
n'y a plus de demande d'adoption que
d'enfant adopté ça a été dit plusieurs
fois tous les projets parentaux ne
peuvent être satisfait à l'heure
actuelle et votre texte va rendre cette
situation douloureuse encore plus tendue
alors certes pour l'image et la
communication politique on fera passer
quelques dossiers en haut de la pile
mais pour les autres couples qui feront
cette demande vous les lancerez contre
un mur de lamentation
administrative la seule échappatoire à
cette aporie du texte tout problème
insolible et inévitable c'est l'adoption
internationale s'il n'est pas possible
de réaliser son projet dans son propre
pays autant aller voir à l'étranger la
seule petite nuance madame la garde des
saut c'est que parmi les pays qui sont
les premiers partenaires des
ressortissants français en matière
d'adoption internation
nombreux sont ceux qui ne partagent pas
votre politique de civilisation et les
transformations que vous souhaitez faire
surbir l'institution familiale et je
continue la Russie est un bon exemple la
Russie est des C nation les plus
sollicité par les ressortissants
français en matière d'adoption
internationale les classements sont
aléatoires selon les années mais l'on
voit la Russie aussilié entre la 3e et
la 5e place de ce classement avec une
moyenne de 400 enfants russes adoptés
par des coupes français ou des
célibataires français tous les ans or la
Russie ne partage pas du tout votre
politique on sait qu'elle triste sort
est encore réservé à ceux qui aiment des
personnes de leur propre jant en Russie
on sait également les progrès que fait
la société russe depuis 20 ans mais le
fait est qu'en l'état actuel des choses
la Russie conservatrice et orthodoxe
refusera très certainement de laisser
ses enfants être adoptés par des coupes
mariés homosexuels cette sitation n'est
pas propre à la Russie malgré ce que dit
Madame Bertinotti et concerne de très
nombreux pays du Sud qui sont
particulièrement attachés au prétendu
conservatisme sur anné que vous entendez
dénoncer d'un trait vous promettez des
adoptions qui n'auront pas lieu parce
que là où vous vous bercez d'illusion et
là où vous bercez des centaines de
milliers de Français dans le my de la
fondation d'une famille grâce au mariage
de couple de même sexe vous ne ferez que
semer la frustration la colère et
l'incompréhension au surplu on connaît
l'issue de ce paradoxe déjà dit
plusieurs fois c'est mécanique c'est la
PMA et la GPA dans 6 mois ou dans 6 ans
j'espère que vous serez plus là dans 6
ans mais quand même vous reviendrez
devant nous pour nous parler d'égalité
de grand principe après nous avoir
promis du bout des lèvres en Séan que
c'est question n'avait rien à voir avec
votre projet de loi et nous serons dans
le domaine du meilleur des mondes à
comme dir
volire tout sera pour le mieux dans le
meilleur des mondes trs bien merci
Monsieur sénateur vous êtes arrivé au
terme de votre intervention merci
monsieur le Président c'est très gentil
de me couper la parole désolé il faut
respecter son temps Monsieur Bruno
rill monsieur le Président madames les
ministres mes chers collègues simplement
quelques remarques
pour répondre pour préciser ma c'est mon
raisonnement euh vis-à-vis de ce que m'a
répondu tout à l'heure madame la la
garde des saau euh sur l'incompétence
négative non je n'ai pas voulu viser ces
articles en particulier j'en visais
d'autres l'article par exemple 310 et et
d'autres articles sur la possession
d'état sur la reconnaissance de
paternité ce que un seul exemple parce
qu'on pourrait discuter très longtemps
de ce que j'ai voulu caractériser un
seul exemple euh jusqu'à présent il y
avait deux obstacles qui fondaient euh
le fait que des couples de même sexe ne
pouvaient pas adopter l'un que le
mariage n'était pas ouvert à ces
couples-là l'autre qu'il y a un principe
d'ordre public vous en conviendrez qui
s'oppose au fait qu'il y ait une double
filiation qu'elle soit d'ailleurs une
filation maternelle ou ou paternelle dès
lors que ce principe d'ordre public
tombe vous pensez bien que c'est tout le
droit de l'affiliation qu'il aurait
fallu revoir voilà voilà simplement ce
que j'ai voulu exprimer ce que je
voulais euh préciser 2uxè chose je n'ai
pas la même lecture des grands arrêts de
la Cour Européenne des droit de l'homme
vous avez deux arrêts l'un qui concerne
euh la France euh de juin euh de l'an
passé 2012 et l'autre qui concerne
l'Autriche il est récent 19 février 2013
dans lequel d'ailleurs la grande chambre
ce qui est assez exceptionnelle de la
CEDH euh pointe d'ailleurs le l'arrêt
euh français dès lors qu'il y a des
situations juridiques identiques vous
devez traiter de la même façon par
exemple sur la PMA sur l'adoption dès
lors qu'il y a une situation juridique
identique et la clé de voûte sur
laquelle
s'appuie le comment dirais-je la cdH qui
est le principe de non discrimination
cette clé de voû là elle la tiendra en
ver et contre tout et je pense que elle
prévaudra ceci dit je vous rassure ni
vous ni moi et pas tellement pour une
question de génération comme le disait
mon excellent collègue pood di Borgo il
y a quelques instants tout simplement
parce que nous avons la conviction que
vous autoriserez la PMA avant même que
la CEDH ait le temps d'être saisi et de
se de statuer sur un cas français c'est
la deuxième remarque qui vous concernait
la troisème remarque concerne la mise
déléguée à la famille que que j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure et je comprends
mieux madame la ministre déléguée je
comprends mieux aujourd'hui que la
vision
relativiste que vous avez des des
familles et moi je les respecte tous je
comprends mieux que avec cette vision le
gouvernement ne cesse de mettre des
coins dans notre politique familiale par
exemple en remettant en cause
l'universalité possiblement des
allocations familiales l'ucation
familiale les dédictions fiscales pour
le service à domicile de de gardant
d'enfant quand on vous entend madame oui
on comprend absolument les visés du
gouvernement qui tendent à ébranler ce
qui fait le socle de notre politique
familiale depuis la deuxème guerre
mondiale ce qui était un consensus bien
sûr vous avez exprimé en peu de mots
finalement votre conception qui est
peut-être celle du gouvernement qui
explique parfaitement les prises de
position du Gouvernement sur le plan de
la politique familiale en France merci
Monsieur Michel Mercier
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame le garde des saau madame le
ministre mes chers collègues tout
d'abord madame le garde des saau comme
d'habitude vous êtes d'une grande
habileté mais je voudrais vous remercier
d'avoir répondu avec respect à chacun
des orateurs vos réponses sont ce
qu'elles sont il y en a certaines qu'on
peut retenir à notre sens d'autres un
peu moins mais elles existent et c'est
bien vous passez d'ailleurs assez
facilement d'arguments de texte à la
général de l'enfant moi je partage ce
que vous avez dit s'agissant des enfants
nés de la GPA ces enfants ne sont pas
responsables de la façon dont ils ont
été conçus et il est donc tout à fait
normal que même si on interdit la GPA
c'est l'état français qui a pas su faire
appliquer sa loi et c'est pas les
enfants qui doivent en supporter les
conséquences moi j'accepte tout à fait
l'idée que le législateur doit aussi se
préoccuper de gouvernement suivant le
cas mais c'est intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant il nous inspire aussi et les
positions qui sont les nôtres en matière
d'adoption plignère alors vous
avez diaboliquement en quelque sorte oui
oui diaboliquement
habile non je non je sa beaucoup dire
j'en ai jamais vu j'ai l'impression que
vous les connaissez mieux que moi mais
pour ma part je pense est que vous avez
été diaboliquement habile en faisant
voter l'article 1er de la loi et c'est
bien entendu vous avez raison
juridiquement vous avez raison de dire
que dès l'URE qu'on touche pas aux
effets du mariage qu' qu'on dit
simplement que le mariage est autorisé
entre deux personnes quel que soit leur
sexe tous les effets du mariage
demeurent mais n'est-ce pas un peu court
quand même s'agissant de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant qu'il y ait pas un
moment de débat et d' interrogation avec
un texte sur l'adoption plainiaire parce
que B le débat a lieu mais pas le texte
et vous savez bien puisque il y a que
cet article
là mais il viendra un autre jour
oui mais aujourd'hui nous parlons du
droit civil des gens et l'adoption c'est
le droit civil des gens et je crois
qu'il aurait fallu très clairement
rappeler quels sont les effets de
l'adoption plainiaire c'est la rupture
d'une filiation existante au profit
d'une nouvelle filiation qui est elle
complètement artificielle et puisqu'elle
n'est pas la filiation réelle l'enfant
est déjà né il avait bien une filiation
il est pas tombé comme ça tout d'un coup
on va gommer cette filiation pour lui en
donner une autre mais il y a un certain
nombre de
conséquences alors je veux pas revenir
sur toutes ces conséquences mais par
exemple des grands-parents de l'enfant
sont des créanciers alimentaires de
l'enfant comment résout l'affaire rien
n'est dit dans le texte et on ne sait
pas comment les choses vont fonctionner
demain parce que on se contente de nous
dire l'ouverture du mariage à deux
personnes du même sexe leur donne le
droit d'adopter c'est évident mais il y
a quand même tout le régime de
l'affiliation tout le régime de
l'adoption c'est et c'est à droit
constant sauf
que cet enfant il est né de parents
biologique sinon il serait pas né et il
fait l'objet d'une adoption et on n pas
réglé la situation N a pas parler il
faudra bien en parler un jour et je
pense que ce cet intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant devait nous conduire avoir un
débat plus approfondi et je partage
aussi au nom de l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant ce que Monsieur monsieur Milon
a dit pour défendre l'amendement qu'il a
soutenu avec Monsieur Pinton et Madame
lard que l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
prime les intérêts des adultes en
présence et impose de ne pas donner à
l'enfant une homophiliation je crois
aussi que cela fait partie de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant le même que vous
avez invoqué et pour justifier et vous
aviez raison l'action que vous avez mené
concernant les enfants nés de la GPA
donc pour cette raison que nous n'avons
plus que ça là parce qu' hier l'article
1 été voté nous avons plus que cet
article pour dire non à l'adoption
pléniaire par des coupes de même sexe
merci alors la parole à Monsieur
richchard monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres mes chers collègues est-il
réellement indifférent que l'enfant soit
élevé ou non par l'homme son père et la
femme sa mère qui lui ont donné la vie
ou deuxè question a-t-on le droit de
priver délibérément un enfant de son
père ou de sa mère en dehors de cas de
défaillance grave et encore dans ces
derniers cas les services sociaux
semblent s'accorder à essayer de ne pas
couper complètement les liens de
l'enfant avec ses parents or n'est-ce
pas ce qui risque de se produire avec
l'instauration de l'adoption plinière
par deux parents du même sexe et surtout
à beaucoup plus grande échelle avec ce
qui suivra un mancablement et dont on
reparlera siôt cette première loi voter
je vise le recours à l'insémination
artificielle puis le recours aux Mair
porteus madame la garde des saau vous
nous indz nous indiquiez tout à l'heure
que sur la PMA et la GPA nos craintes
n'avaient pas lieu d'être disiez-vous
puisque je ne vous cite certainement pas
parfaitement j'ouvre néanmoins les
Guillaumet si la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme avait dû prendre une
décision à cet égard elle aurait déjà pu
le faire compte tenu des antécédents
d'ouverture du mariage homosexuel
intervenu dans d'autres pays d'Europe
vous avez cité notamment l'Espagne or et
ça cela a été dit tout à l'heure par
notre collègue Bruno retaillot vous
semblez oublier madame la garde des saau
que ce n'est que très récemment le 19
février 2013 exactement que la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a
condamné l'Autriche au nom de
l'égalité pour avoir refusé d'envisager
l'adoption d'un enfant par la compagne
de sa mère alors que le père qui payait
une pension alimentaire et voyait
régulièrement son enfant s'opposait à
cette adoption nous sommes bien dans ce
cas de
figure pour ma
part poser les questions que je viens de
citer c'est déjà y répondre la charte
des nations- Unies des droits de
l'enfant voté par l'ensemble des
sociétés formant notre humanité abonde
d'ailleurs clairement dans ce sens dans
son article 7 je cite cette fois
parfaitement l'enfant a le droit de
connaître son père et sa mère et d'être
élevé par eux c'est la raison pour
laquelle et parce qu'effectivement c'est
la la dernière fois où nous pourrons
véritablement influer peut-être sur ce
vote je me permet d'insister à cet égard
et que je voterai donc l'amendement
déposé par monsieur le président zooketo
et ses collègues de l'Union centriste
merci mes chers collègues j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe socialiste sur l'amendement les
amendements
174 rectifié TER et 210
rectifié je vous rappelle que l'avis de
la commission est défavorable l'avis du
Gouvernement est défavorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public article 56 le
scrutin sera ouvert Dansel quelques
instants
le scrutin est
ouvert
salut
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos je demande au secrétaire de
bien
vouloir procéder au
dépouillement
voici le résultat du scrutin 152 portant
sur les amendement 174 rectifi et 210
rectifié nombre de votants 34 43
suffrage exprimé 340 majorité absolue
171 pour l'adoption 164 contre
176 le Sénat n'a pas
adopté monsieur Lenoir vous voulez faire
un rappel très rapide rappel au
règlement monsieur le Président je sais
que vos travaux sont très suivis à
l'extérieur à la fois sur les canaux
spécialisés mais également sur Internet
et alors je vais aider les personnes qui
regardent notre séance comprendre pour
qu'elle comprenne ce qui s'est passé il
y a eu un scutin public évidemment il n
a pas les commentaires je vais me
permettre de faire le commentaire qui
s'impose en
fait la gauche est
minoritaire les sénateurs de gauche ne
sont pas suffisamment nombreux alors
qu'on était appelé à voter une
disposition importante qu' un amendement
qui voulait bifer tout le dispositif
concernant l'adoption pour les couples
homosexuels et donc comme alors je
continue mon commentaire comme ils ne
sont pas assz nom
il aé demandé un scrutin public qui
permet à des personnes qui ne sont pas
présentes de participer au vote alors
que dans No r um centriste nous étions
beaucoup plus nombreux voilà le
commentaire que je voulais faire merci
monsieurénateur acte vous est donné nous
passons maintenant à l'examen d'une
série d'amendements en discussion
commune le premier d'entre amendement 81
rectifi la parole à Monsieur Gard merci
monsieur le Président cet amendement est
un peu un amendement
armatomique en effet j'ai rendu hommage
tout à l'heure à notre rapporteur pour
l'effort qu'il avait fait en essayant de
d'harmoniser ou de rendre plus facile
les problèmes posés par l'adoption mais
l'effort les efforts de notre rapporteur
me paraissent insuffisant parce qu'il
soulève d'autres problèmes tout aussi
grave et tout aussi important ainsi par
exemple pour
l'adoption d'un enfant par un membre
d'un couple homosexuel et bien on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a pas une solution
qu'il y en a 5 ou si
différentes certains enfants ne seront
pas
adoptable parce qu'ils ont un père et
une
mère d'autres enfants ne seront pas
adoptable non plus pour d'autres raisons
certains ne pourront être adoptés que
par l'adoption pliniiare d'autres que
par l'adoption simple et d'ut par aucune
adoption il y a donc ici une atteinte au
principe d'égalité et en fin de compte
l'étude d'impact n'a pas étudié les
conséquences de ces différentes
situations de cette atteinte au principe
d'égalité et face à cette situation je
ne vois qu'une seule solution c'est de
mettre en standby notre législation sur
l'adoption qui est devenue totalement
inadapté d'autant plus rappelons-le que
l'adoption pliniiaire est irrévocable et
que par conséquent elle ne peut pas
tenir compte des possibilités
éventuelles avec tous les risques que
cela comporte de divorce ultérieur c'est
la raison pour laquelle je vous propose
donc de suspendre le titre 8 du livre
premier du Code civil concernant
l'adoption en attendant que soit adoptée
cette grande loi sur la famille dont on
parle depuis le début de nos débats bien
merci l'amendement 208 rectifié bis
monsieur Milon
oui monsieur le Président cet amendement
208 rectif B avait tout son sens si les
amendements de suppression avaient été
votés je je le maintiens quand même
parce que ça me permet de m'exprimer
toujours sur l'adoption pliniiaire
l'amendement 208 permettait l'adoption
pliniiaèire d'un des deux conjoints mais
pas du conjoint joint de celui qui avait
obtenu l'adoption pliniiare nous
estimons que l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant qui prime les intérêts des
adultes en présence impose de ne pas
donner à à l'enfant une homophiliation
et de le faire apparaître à l'état civil
comme étant issu de deux hommes ou de
deux femmes je voudrais à la suite de
Bruno rotaillot revenir sur la Cour
européenne parce que la Cour européenne
peut nous condamner pour discrimination
non pas sur l'affiliation mais bien sur
la parentalité qu'elle peut nous
condamner et c'est peut-être la
confusion que fait actuellement le
gouvernement ce que dit la Cour
européenne c'est que on ne doit pas
discriminer une famille
homoparentale l'intérêt de l'enfant
c'est sa filiation et avec l'adoption
simple on reconnaît la famille
homoarental l'adoption pliniiare elle
pour deux personnes de même sexe prive
cet enfant de la possibilité d'avoir une
filiation conforme à la réalité
biologique ce qui n'est évidemment pas
le cas d'adoption simple l'enfant est
est élevé par deux femmes ou par deux
hommes il y a évidemment plusieurs
formes de parentalité mono recomposé et
cetera mais chacun d'entre nous n'a
qu'une filiation et c'est pourquoi
l'adoption plainère est-elle irrévocable
l'enfant peut avoir des beaux parents au
gré des unions et des désunions des
adultes mais il a droit à la pérénité de
son statut qui passe par saffiliation en
voulant la Peinière pour les couples
homosexuel vous faites preuve
excusez-moi du terme j'en ai pas trouvé
d'autres un petit peu d'hypocrisie vous
avez l'intention au bout du compte de la
détruire parce que l'adoption par un
couple homosexuel ne rentre pas dans
l'affiliation classique du titre 7 il
sera nécessaire de déclasser cette
adoption pliniiaire Madame bertinoti et
Monsieur suer d'ailleurs veulent revoir
l'état civil des adoptés pligners qui
actuellement est le même que celui des
enfants classiques ce serait alors une r
par rapport à la loi de
1996 merci amendement 238 madame
bembassa je défendrai ici les amendem
238 et
239 qui poursuivent le même objet le 238
concerne l'adoption plainiaère le 239
l'adoption simple en l'état de notre
droit une personne peut adopter de
manière plainère ou simple l'enfant de
son conjoint dans les conditions posées
par la loi le droit ne fait alors aucune
distinction entre les enfants et c'est
heureux puisque faut-il le rappeler les
hommes naissent et demeurent libres et
égaux en droit mais depuis les deux
arrêts de cassation de
1991 et 2003 on observe une véritable
rupture d'égalité entre les enfants en
fonction de leur mode de conception en
effet la Cour de cassation a refusé
l'adoption par le conjoint du parent
d'enfant né par gestation pour autrui à
l'étranger au motif que cette pratique
contrevenait à l'ordre public français
il ne s'agit pas ici je le rappelle et
j'insiste une nouvelle fois de légaliser
la GPA en France il s'agit de faire
primer l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
et le principe d'égalité sans autre
considération
morale nous souhaitons donc que soit
rappelé aux articles concernés du Code
civil que l'adoption de l'enfant du
conjoint peut et doit être prononcé
uniquement en tenant compte de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'ENF enfant cet intérêt
supérieur que vous mettez en en scène
inlassablement depuis plusieurs jours et
non de son mode de
conception cet amendement relève
uniquement du respect de la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen que
j'ai cité précédemment et la Convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
qui dispose à son article
3-1 que dans toutes les décisions qui
concernent les enf enfant qu'elle soit
le fait des institutions publiques ou
privées de protection sociale des
tribunaux des autorités administrativ ou
des organes législatives l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant doit être une
considération primordiale fin de
citation j'ajoute de nouveau avec
insistance que le vrai intérêt de
l'enfant celui est celui de lui préparer
un avenir digne de ce
nom merci le 2 rectifié B monsieur Midon
monsieur
Midon sur le 211 au rectifier bis
oui monsieur le Président éit toujours
dans l'article 1ier bis à l'alignée 2
après les mots conjoint nous proposons
avec mes collègues de d'insérer les mots
de sexe différents toujours pour les
mêmes raisons il convient de préciser
que le droit de l'affiliation interdit
une double filiation maternelle ou
paternelle merci
nous en venons au 120 rectifié bis de
Monsieur
retaillot également peut-être le 121
rectifi B
oui je peux les si vous voulez monsieur
le Président justement madame mesdames
les ministres et mes chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
rapporteur aussi je voudrais d'ailleurs
indiquer que et et rendre justice au
rapporteur ce qu' a dit Philippe B est
très exact il a essayé de contenir un
certain nombre de dem age que le premier
texte sorti de l'Assemblée nationale
causait en matière d'adoption même de
pluréadoption nous
sommes peu d'accord sur beaucoup de
choses mais quand nous le sommes enfin
en tout cas autant rendre à César ce qui
est à César quand quand c'est la vérité
alors cet amendement je vois pas
d'ailleurs en quoi vous pourriez lui
être défavorable madame la
ministre puisque c'est un amendement qui
reprend donc l'article 345 du du Code
civil euh pour l'adoption des des
enfants de de de 13 ans de moins 13 ans
et l'idée c'est d'ajouter un dispositif
pour que avant de donner son
consentement l'enfant dans une période
qui est une période de l'adolescence
difficile où parfois les enfants ont du
mal à verbaliser un consentement qu'il
est une aide l'aide d'un psychologue
pour pouvoir l'éclairer pour pouvoir
discuter faire en sorte sorte que son
consentement soit vraiment éclairé son
consentement si je dire vienne du du
cœur et que ce soit un
consentement véritablement réfléchi je
pense qu'on ne peut pas s'opposer à ce
dispositif on le peut d'ailleurs
d'autant moins que si j'ai bien créé
compris vous souhaitez créer une
filiation précisément sociale la volonté
pour vous est quelque chose extrêmement
important donc vous comprendrez que
faire en sorte que pour un adolescent de
13 ans cette volonté puisse être
éclairée ça le soit
aussi alors pour ce qui concerne le
deuxème amendement mais vous me monsieur
le Président vous me remettrez à compte
vous me tiendrez compte de du chrono à
peu de chos près alors moi je suis pas
du tout d'accord avec notre collègue ben
Bassa bien sûr sur l'amendement qu'elle
a proposé et l'amendement que je
présente maintenant c'est un amendement
qui tend vraiment à
proscrire
les éléments qui pourrai nous amener à
la PMA et puis à la
GPA le problème j'ai bien compris vous
vous souhaitez la légaliser à l'étranger
vous souhaitez la régulariser à
l'étranger mais ça revient au même vous
affaibliriez notre cohérence notre
cohérence juridique madame vous le savez
bien et et mais vous assumez vous
assumez moi j'ai beaucoup de respect je
pense que seul les convictions tièdes
sont moins respectueuses les convictions
fermes sont sont le sont toujours même
si on n pas d'accord mais je vous le dis
moi je suis pas d'accord et l'amendement
c'est que le problème aujourd'hui avec
ce texte qui ouvre l'adoption on le voit
bien le problème c'est que pour que
l'adoption produise ses effets il y a
pas 36000 solutions c'est pas l'adoption
internationale il y a de moins en moins
d'enfants adopt pour plein de raisons la
convention de la qui dispose que faut
d'abord épuiser toutes les solutions
pour l'adoption dans le pays d'origine
il y a l'amélioration de la condition
des femmes et cetera et cetera bien donc
cette source là elle sera rarissime il
faut le redire donc donc la voix de
l'adoption ce sera la voix de l'adoption
du conjoint de solution soit qu'il y ait
eu
antérieurement un enfant soit que il
soit si j'ose dire fabriquer entre
guillemets un enfant àoc et c'est là qui
est le problème un premier problème qui
serait que cette loi veuille régulariser
contourner finalement des dispositions
encore une fois d'ordre publique
notamment euh le Code civil l'article 16
indisponibilité du corps humain sur la
GPA sur aussi la PMA de convenance et
Alain Milon avait raison de rappeler que
la PMA concerne aussi les couples
htérosexuels PMA pour convenance voilà
et il s'agit pas de séparer l'une de
l'autre bien mais il s'agit d'une d'un
texte qui peut amener à contourner à
contourner ses disposition d'ordre
publici et notamment le code de la santé
publique euh avec l'article 21 41 411 et
412 donc il s'agit très clairement de
dire non pas plus pour aujourd'hui que
pour demain et là je pense que en
acceptant en adoptant cet amendement
vous enverriez un signal vous leveriez
toute ambiguïé puisque vous cessiez de
nous dire que la la la PMA et et la GPA
n'est pas l'horizon d'après le texte et
bien vous régleriez définitivement cette
question en adoptant cet
amendement
merci alors nous poursuivons avec le 164
rectifié monsieur
BCO monsieur le Président merci monsieur
le Président Madame le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur alors cet amendement 164
rectifié complète un article ainsi
rédigé au paragraphe l'article 345 du
même code est complété par un NA ainsi
rédigé toutefois l'adoption n'est pas
permise lorsque l'enfant a été conçu
dans le cadre d'une gestation pour le
compte d'autrui ou d'une technique de
procréation médicale assistée interdite
par la législation française alors cet
amendement c'est un amendement d'appel
en fait un amendement d'appel qui qui
pose le problème je dirais
mais et qui n'apporte peut-être pas de
solution immédiate du
moins parce que la PMA est autorisée en
droit français pour les couples de
personnes de même sexe
euh de de sexe différents pouris
médicale seulement la GPA est interdite
en autre législation alors certains
n'hésitent pas à contourner la loi
française en ayant recours à la PMA
alors comme me dit Alain Milon j'appelis
la PMA de de convenance ou la GPA à
l'étranger ce détournement de la loi
française peut-être le fait de coupe de
sexes différents qui n'entre pas dans
les critères légaux de la PMA enoit
français ils vont à l'étranger afin de
bénéficier d'une PMA de convenance il
est également le fait de couple de
personnes de même sexe qui ont recours à
la PMA de convenance hors de France en
Belgique en Espagne car elle ne leurit
pas ouverte ainsi que la GPA en France
les personnes ayant fait l'objet ayant
fait appel à ces méthodes de procréation
interdite en France l'ont fait en
connaissance de cause elles sont
informées des conséquences juridiques
que leur démarche va entraîner elles
mettent le législateur devant un fait
accompli en lui demandant d'y
remédier est-ce bien là notre
faire jouer des conséquences et des
méthodes de procréation interdit en
France constitue un détournement de la
loi française et et ça c'est
inadmissible les enfants ainsi conçus
sont délibérément privés d'une filiation
paternelle ou maternel afin d'être
adopté par le compagnon ou la compagne
de la mère ou du père biologique en
admettant l'adoption par le compagnon ou
la compagne du parent biologique d'un
enfant né par PMA ou par GPA pratique à
l'étranger on ouvre la porte à la
légalisation de la PMA et de convenance
et de la GPA en droit français cette
ouverture sera inéductable car selon les
moyens leurs moyens financiers les uns
pourront et les autres ne pourront pas
accéder à l'étranger au nom toujours du
principe d'égalité on nous demandera
dans un dans peu de temps d'autoriser la
PMA de convenance et la GPA pourquoi pas
en droit français ce sera inéductable
l'adoption aura été un moyen d'accès à
la PMA de convenance et à la GPA pour
les coupes de personnes de même sexe une
fois sa méthode procréative autorisée
l'adoption n'aura plus d'objet car
pourquoi attendre des années avant
d'obtenir un agrément alors qu'avec la
PMA de convenance ou la GPA on aura à
l'è accès à l'enfant de son choix
assouplissons leurs conditions
d'application mais ne bouleversçons pas
tout le droit de la famille pour
répondre au désirs de quelques-uns
merci
merci sur le 166 rectifié monsieur lu
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
l'amendement que j'ai l'honneur de
présenter dans la foulée de Bruno
rotaillot et et de Michel beccco est un
amendement que je vais qualifier de
mesure non pas de mesure autant au titre
de l'équilibre de la mesure des choses
entre vous et nous mais de mesure de
votre sincérité madame la ministre
puisque vous nous avez dit à juste titre
que la PMA n'était pas du tout du
périmètre de cette loi et encore moins
la GPA on veut bien vous croire et je
crois également le premier ministre et
le président de la République qui a dit
que lui vivant lui
président la
GPA la GPA ne serait jamais voter dans
notre
pays puisque le président de la
République a dit que la GPA ne sera
jamais en vigueur dans notre pays la
France vous madame la ministre madame la
garde des saau vous devez évidemment
accompagner cette volonté présidentielle
qui à la limite l'honneur en bloquant le
périmètre de la
glissade et donc vous avez là l'occasion
avec cet amendement que je qualifie de
mesure de prouver que vous êtes sincère
quand vous dites que vous ne voulez pas
la GPA puisque cet amendement arrête en
réalité la capacité
d'adoption dans le cadre d'une
éventuelle GPA alors nous attendons
votre réponse et je serais très heureux
que vous accompagniez et que vous
donniez un avis favorable à cet
amendement
merci l'amendement numéro 202 monsieur
revet oui merci monsieur le Président
Madame euh garde des saut madame le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement que j'ai déposére collègue
philiip d'arnich s'inscrit dans la même
démarche et vous avez bien compris
qu'elle participe de toutes les
interrogations que suscite le texte que
vous nous proposez et que quelque
part nous voulons aussi mettre des
sécurités comme vient de le dire mon
collègue Jean-Pierre lelleu et nous
garantir contre des excès ou des fait
qui pourrait intervenir suite à
l'adoption du texte de loi et donc c'est
pour ça que nous avons déposer ces
amendements et vous avez compris que
c'est important parce que c'est vrai que
la même teneur pour différents
amendements déposés mais c'est parce que
nous sommes très attentifs et très
inquiets de ce qui pourrait
advenir merci amendement numéro 251
notre collègue alain
GOURNAC
madame la ministre vous a écouté avec
une attention soutenue quand vous nous
avez répondu tout à l'heure et comme
j'ai j'étais en partie convaincu de ce
que vousz dit l'intérêt de l'enfant vous
le partage avec nous je doutais pas
avant pas sur ce terrain mais vous nous
avez bien dit le texte qui vous proposé
il est clair n précis il est cerné il
est enfermé il s'agit du
mariage
pour les personnes du même sexe et puis
d'adoption je vous ai écouté je dit bah
au moins là les choses sont claires et
ça correspond bien qu' on vient de
l'entendre à ce qu'a dit le président de
la République vous avez des collègues
qui ont pas dit la même chose mais ça
c'est
habituel et donc pour vous aider pour
vous aider j'ai dit mais moi il faut
absolument que je reprenne cette cet
amendement en
faisant évoluer les choses et en
empêchant ce que vous ne voulez pas la
GPA PMA et donc de le mettre dans le
texte et on verra bien quand on va
discuter de la globalité sur la la de la
la loi de la famille et qu'on regardera
les choses et donc c'est vraiment pour
éviter tout risque aller dans votre sens
que vous nous avez déclaré ici que je
propose cet amendement qui est facile
toutefois l'adoption n'est pas permise
lorsque l'enfant a été conçu dans le
cadre d'une gestion pour le compte
d'autrui ou d'une technique de
procréation médicale assistée interdite
par la législation française donc voilà
on le met noir sur blanc on est
tranquille et ça sécurise tout le monde
et on met pas ces enfants en danger
merci amendement 231 rectifié monsieur
dernich merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
et bien c'est le même amendement je l'ai
défendu tout à l'heure je l'ai défendu
lors de de mon explication préalable euh
et et je voudrais dire simplement que
euh
la réponse est simple comme l'a dit mon
mon collègue alain GOURNAC à l'instant
la réponse est simple nous l'attendons
puisque aujourd'hui nous savons que la
loi interdit la gestation pour autrui et
circonscrit l'accès aux techniques
d'assistance médicale à la prramation au
seul couple dans l'infertilité est
d'origine médicale si on fait une
entorse à ces principes ça aurait des
conséquences en cascade contraire à
l'intérieur sup à l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant et à la dignité humaine
l'organisation par exemple par la loi de
la conception d'enfants privés de père
ou de mère on le sait mais la violation
peut-être des lois fondamentales de
bioéthique qui ne peuvent pas être
modifié sans recourir à un large débat
préalable et surtout en cas de GPA en
cas de GPA l'atteinte à la dignité des
femmes et au principe fondamental
d'indisponibilité du corps humain donc
autoriser l'adoption d'enfants conçus à
l'étranger dans le cadre de pratique
interdite en France reviendrait Infiné à
légitimer et et à légaliser ses
pratiques c'est la raison pour laquelle
je souhaite que cet amendement soit
accepté par l'ensemble de Parlement
merci alors sur ces amendements quel est
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
je vais les prendre les un derrière les
autres ou presque l'amendement de
Monsieur
Géard sur le fond on pe être d'accord
avec le doy gellard je l'ai dit
plusieurs fois c'est que la législation
actuelle de l'adoption pliniiaèire n'est
pas adaptée au réalité de l'adoption
d'auourd'hui notamment quant à la
possibilité pour les enfants de
connaître leurs origines et que donc ça
nécessite une réforme tout le monde l'a
dit ici mais le doen Géard lui il va
dans l'arme c'est plus que l'arme
atomique c'est la bazooka il n dit plus
que c'est comme ça et ben on supprime
totalement toute la législation sur
l'adoption c'est-à-dire que si c'était
adopté à partir de quelques semaines
plus personne ne pourrait adopter même
les coupes les procédures en cours
s'arrêteraient immédiatement donc on
voit bien que le Do Gard veut
insister lourdement auprès du
gouvernement pour que il revoit
rapidement et moi aussi d'ailleurs la
législation sur l'adoption mais mais il
sait très bien que cet amendement ne
peut pas être adopté en l'état et donc
la commission des lois donn un avis
défavorable monsieur mon euh monsieur
mon votre amendement a un double objet
euh le deuxième objet qui est dans le
dans la ligne de ce que vous avez dé
déjà dit c'est d'interdire l'adoption
pour les coues du même sexe voilà vous
êtes vous avez dit que vous étiez
finalement favorable au texte parce que
voilà mais vous auriez voulu que mais
vous savez très bien
que c'est là où la
commission où la cour euré droits de
l'homme n'urait pas été d'accord c'est
que le mariage l'adoption pour tous les
couples et donc voilà donc sur ce
deuxème point c'est vraiment dans la
droite ligne par contre euh le premier
objet de votre amendement est quand même
assez curieux puisque euh il autorise
l'adoption par le partenaire du parent
le partenaire n'est pas un terme
juridique voilà alors si c'est des gens
qui viennent qui vivent en concubinage
bon le partenaire du parent sera un
célibataire aux yeux de la loi et bon il
pourra adopter ou pas ça dépendra de de
l'agrément et du jugement d'adoption
s'il ait dans paxé alors il fallait le
dire c'est interdit aujourd'hui je crois
que dans le cours du débat il y a un
amendement je ne sais plus de qui qui
autorise d'adoption plinière par les
coupes paxés voilà donc cet amendement
est assez vraiment sur sur porte sur
deux sujets qui sont très distinctes
mais la Commission a émit tout de même
un avis
défavorable l'amendement de Madame
Benbassa est tout à fait différent et
d'ailleurs contraire dans un certain
sens aux amendements suivant notamment à
partir du 120 euh au partir du 121
rectifié de Monsieur retaillot Madame
ben Bassa prend en compte des situations
qui existent
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire que elle nous
dit et nous le savons qu'il y a des
enfants dans des couples qui sont nés
soit par PMA soit par
GPA que ces enfants sont là et que ils
n'ont pas le même statut que les autres
la circulaire de Madame lagardesso
uniquement réglé problème dans certains
cas de leur nationalité mais pas de leur
état civil et donc Madame Benbassa nous
dit et bien ces enfants pourraient être
adoptés quel que
soit quel que soit le mode de conception
du
conjoint alors madame Benbassa même si
je comprends tout à fait le sens de
votre amendement même si comme vous en
tant que rapporteur du texte j'ai reçu
un certain nombre d'associations ou de
de familles qui existent et qui sont
dans ce cas-là je ne peux pas donner un
avis favorable à votre amendement et
donc à titre personnel je vous inviterai
à le retirer tout à l'heure sinon il
sera repoussé par il sera repoussé même
si même si à la suite d'un vote un peu
compliqué la commission avé un avis
favorable mais ça m'étonnerait que en
séance on retrouve cet avis favorable
vous savez en commission on peut rentrer
et
sortir ensuite nous avons l'amendement
200 nous
avons en séance aussi oui mais en séance
il y a des délégations de vote qu'on
qu'on a pas en commission de la même
manière
ensuite nous avons le 21 rectifié de
Monsieur Millon qui est le même que le
précédent puisque il interdit l'adoption
pliniiaire pour les couples de même sexe
il a réserve au coupe de même de sex
différents avis défavoraable
également ensuite l'amendement à c'est
intéressant bien que curieux de Monsieur
retaillot c'est le 120 rectifié en effet
monsieur le sénateur d'abord je vous
remercie des paroles obligeantes que
vous avez à mon égard et j'enurai
également au
vôtre le mineur DEP de 13 ans alors on
parle de
l'adoption comment adoption
métropolitaine nationale pas d'adoption
internationale puisque là le jugement
aura lieu à l'étranger donc dans ce
cas-là le Mineur de plus de 13 ans il
est appelé à consentir à C adoption le
conseil de famille vous le savez mieux
que moi puisque vous êtes président du
conseil général comme beaucoup d'autres
de nos collègues ici c'est le conseil de
famille de conseil général qui propose
l'adoption et cetera bon l'enfant de
plus de 13 ans doit consentir celui de
moins de 13 ans ça dépend de l'âge mais
s'il dit NON et NON et NON je veux pas
être adopté je m' réfère à ceux qui sont
là ça m'étonnerait que le Conseil
Général l'oblige être adopté il
continuera il restera confié à
l'assistance à laaz voilà donc dans ce
cas-là il doit consentir et vous dites
alors après parce que Monsieur retaillot
peut-être n'avez-vous pas une confiance
extrême dans et les enquêtes d'aide
social que vous allez faire faire et le
juge vous dites il faut forcément un
entretien avec un
psychologue
alors je vous dirai
si déjà quand le dossier
arrive devant le tribunal il est assez
fourni moimême dans une existence
antérieure j'ai été juge à non substittu
à une première chambre de tribunal à
créteille il y avait beaucoup d'affaires
d'adoption et les les dossiers du
conseil général arrivai avec bon une
enquête très complète de l'aide sociale
et souvent d'ailleurs une enquête Médico
Psychologique psychologique et cetera
bon donc le juge si il voit que c'est
insuffisant si il se heurte à des
difficulté venant de l'enfant qu'il peut
entendre et bien il il peut ordonner
tous les examens complémentaires avant
de prendre sa décision sa décision est
un jugement et je pense que le juge fera
ce qu'il faut pour être assez éclairé
avant de prononcer l'adoption
c'est-à-dire comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même tous le fait que l'enfant
rentre totalement dans la famille de ses
parents et que
jusqu'à ce que
éventuellement la législation soit
modifiée il perd tout repère avec sa
famille d'origine même si en a plus
officiellement mais elle peut toujours
se réveiller un jour donc nous avons
donné un avis défavorable à cet
amendement parce que nous pensons qu'il
n la Commission a trouvé qu'il était pas
totalement nécessaire et qu'il
surchargerait le texte et que les
conditions que vous mettez sont toujours
possibles par le juge de
l'adoption ensuite nous avons 1 2 3 4 5
et six amendements semblables totalement
semblables qui interdisent
contrairement finalement à l'esprit de
l'amendement de Madame Bassa qui
interdisent totalement
l'adoption pour tous les
couples si les enfants adoptables c'est
des adoptions d'ailleurs parental au
sein d'un couple sont né soit par BMA
soit par GPA pour la GPA mes chers
collègues le problème est réglé il est
réglé par un arrêt de la première
chambre de la Cour de cassation du 6
avril
2011 considérer que ça n'était pas
possible parce que
l'origine l'origine la conception des
enfants est trs contraire à notre droit
et
à voilà à l'ordre public voilà donc je
considère
que d'autre part traiter de de la PMA
aujourd'hui ça me paraît totalement en
avance sur ce qui sera peut-être fait
plus tard alors qu'aujourd'hui on n'en
sait rien donc je pense que ces
amendements doivent être repoussés je
voudrais ajouter que le
rapporteur le rapporteur et le
rapporteur de l'ensemble du
Sénat et de la commission des lois qui
représente l'ensemble du Sénat donc le
rapporteur il donne l'avis de la
commission il peut arriver comme tout à
l'heure que donner mon avis personnel
mais on voit très bien que finalement
cet avis personnel aurait correspondu
dans notre circonstance à la vie de la
Commission et donc le rapporteur il est
à votre entière
disposition
totalement simplement mes chers
collègues oui et notamment je le demande
à ceux qui ont été les plus assidus dans
les dans les entretiens préalable dans
les je vous demande de faciliter quand
même l'avancée de nos travaux je crois
que ça serait bien à ce stade où nous en
sommes je vous remerci mer quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement madame la
gardesso monsieur le Président donc il y
a effectivement plusieurs série
d'amendements alors d'abord
effectivement le l'amendement du Doyen
géin qui l'a appelé lui-même
l'armatomique je conviens aussi que
c'est l'armatomique la suppression de la
totalité du titre 8 du Code civil qui va
des articles
300 343 je crois
370 voilà donc vous supprimez toute
possibilité d'adoption vous éliminez le
cadre juridique dans lequel s'effectue
l'adoption alors que nous savons tous
qu'il y a des procédures en cours donc
je pense je je crois que le le
rapporteur a raison quand il dit que
c'est une interpellation forte j'allais
presque dire absolu euh parce que l'arme
atomique elle est totalement
destructrice hein c'est aucun de nous
n'y survit ni survivra ni survivrait
hein alors que nous avons encore de si
belles choses à faire donc le
gouvernement entend parfaitement et
l'engagement Ava été pris je le réitère
ici euh le projet de loi sur la famille
va travailler en profondeur sur tout
notre régime d'adoption parce
queeffectivement il y a des
interrogation de fond dessus pour C
cette raison j'ai pas envie de dire en
avis des favor il me coûte toujours
d'avoir l'impression de de vous être
désagréable monsieur doyen Géard mais je
suis sûre que le gouvernement vous ayant
entendu la commission également et
l'ensemble des parlementaires vous
déciderez peut-être le retrait de cet
amendement sur il y a donc une autre
série d'amendements euh alors parmi les
amendements de Monsieur le sénateurillot
il y a le l'inscription dans la loi de
l'obligation pour un enfant de 13 ans
don le consentement est prévu par la loi
déjà que il puisse être assisté d'un
psychologue euh d'abord c'est une
disposition pratique hein d'être assisté
par un psychologue c'est une décision
que prennent les juges qu'il s'agit d'un
psychologue d'une assistante sociale
d'un médecin d'un psychiatre ce sont des
décisions pratiques qui sont prises en
opportunité par le magistrat saisi d'une
affaire et en l'occurrence donc d'une
décision d'adoption en l'état actuel du
droit il est possible déjà pour le juge
de décider qu'un enfant de 13 ans si son
attitude si lui-même en fait la demande
le le magistrat peut aller il ira plus
loin que ce que vous voulez inscrire
dans le texte à savoir un psychologue
puisque il peut décider d'un d' d'une
d'un entretien avec un psychologue avec
un médecin avec un médicopsychologue ou
ou plus donc voilà pour ces raisons
parce que votre inquiétude est déjà
satisfaite par le droit et parce que ce
serait introduit IR en mesure juridique
une disposition pratique le l'avis du
Gouvernement est défavorable sur les
amendements qui concernent la
l'autorisation d'adoption d'enfants nés
de GPA il y a soit la présomption de
naissance de GPA soit la certitude de
naissance de GPA essentiellement votre
amendement madame la sénatrice Esther
benbassin nous avons
sur cette certitude sur la certitude qui
est rarissime convenantant sur la
certitude euh puisque la gestation pour
autruille est contraire à l'ordre euh
public français et que le Président de
la République a affirmé réaffirmé
soutenu confirmé par le Premier ministre
que pendant tout son quinquena il est
pas question de revenir sur le principe
d'indisponibilité du corps humain donc
d'introduire ne serait-ce qu'un débat
sur la GPA alors que pour la PMA voilà
très clairement le Président le premier
ministre a dit que ce sera dans le texte
sous réserve évidemment de
l'appréciation qu'il portera sur le
rapport rapport du du Conseil national
d'éthique bon mais sur la GPA il n'y a
pas la moindre ambigué il y a pas la
moindre ouverture la la parole du
président est est est formelle donc il y
a des des cas extrêmement rares de
certitude sur la GPA et puis il y a les
cas de présomption sur les cas de
certitude nous avons un jugement de
2003 qui euh formule très précisément
que compte tenu du fait que l'enfant
concerné était né de GPA que cela a été
établi
le le tribunal a refusé d'autoriser
l'adoption de cet enfant donc nous avons
comme référence pour l'instant la
jurisprudence euh introduire dans le
droit la possibilité de d'adopter un
enfant né de GPA si on est en situation
de de certitude c'est contrevenir aux
dispositions du droit civil et notamment
donc de l'article 16 alinéa 7 qui pose
bien très clairement l'interdiction du
recours à la GPA et et en tant que
principe d'ordre public donc absolu sans
la moindre dérogation possible
évidemment si on n'est pas dans une
certitude mais dans une présomption et
que le juge saisit pour l'adoption pour
la décision d'adoption estime que dans
l'intérêt de l'enfant il faudrait
autoriser l'adoption moi je ne doute pas
que nos magistrats prononceraient une
autorisation d'adoption si l'intérêt de
l'enfant est en jeu pour ces raisons je
vous
propose de retir cet amendement parce
que le débat que vous avez provoqué
était nécessaire ces éclaircissements
devaient être posés il ils l'ont été
grâce à cet amendement et je je vous
propose de le retirer je ne doute pas
que vous ne souhaitez pas aller contre
l'ordre public français en la
matière et pour les autres pour les
autres amendements qui consistent pardon
monsieur le
sénateur comm en toute matière
absolument bien bien entendu en celle-là
puisque nous débattons de celle-là en
d'autres circonstances nous aurons
reconfirmé voilà pour les derniers
amendements qui consiste à interdire la
GPA nous n'en voyons pas l'utilité donc
puisque c'est interdit par le droit donc
avis défavorable du gouvernement sauf
les deux demandes de retrait adressé au
doyen Géard et à madame la sénatrice ben
bassin je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement 81 rectifié qu'inquè sur
sur le sur lequel sur lequel j'ai une
demande d'explication de vote de Madame
besego en fait non mais excusez-moi
c'est c'est malheureux ça dès que je
veux prendre la parole je sais pas ce
qui se passe là tout d'un coup il y a de
la fièvre là de ce côté des bans je sais
pas alors monsieur le Président je
voulais utiliser mon temps de parole
d'explication de vote en posant une
question à Madame la gardessau qui est
une question
que se pose actuellement tous les maires
et donc je pense que vous aurez à cœur à
un moment donné ou un autre de me
répondre madame lagardessau en fait et
c'était en marge de des amendements de
Monsieur Milon notamment sur la la la la
la double filiation maternelle et
paternelle ou l'homofiliation en fait
vous avez dit hier très simplement vous
avez dit hier que sur le livret de
famille qui certes n'est pas qui est du
domaine réglementaire je sais bien mais
je dis qui concerne Vim tous nos Maes
vous avez dit que ça serait un document
unique parce que moi je vous écoute très
bien et qui serait évolué nous avions
compris un certain nombre que vous aviez
dit par ailleurs notamment devant
l'Assemblée nationale que les termes de
père et mère ne disparaîtraient pas et
certains d'entre nous avaient compris
qu'il y aurait trois livrets de famille
donc hier j'ai entendu un livret unique
si à un moment donné du débat madame le
gardesso vous pouviez nous donner une
précision là-dessus je pense que tous
les maires de notre pays apprécier merci
beaucoup merci la parole est à notre
collègue Patrice
gellard monsieur le Président je
voudrais d'abord faire deux petites
remarques sur ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure la première remarque c'est que
la Russie interdit les adoptions
monoparentales donc il c'est pas
possible ça n'existe pas et et la
deuxième remarque que je voulais faire
mais je n'ai pas les chiffres ils ont
été donnés au moment des auditions c'est
que que la plupart des enfants qui
vivraient dans les familles cette
fois-ci
homoparental seraient des enfants qui
ont un père et une mère bon je ferme
cette parenthèse et j'en viens à la
demande à la fois de notre rapporteur et
madame le garde desess saau pour leur
dire que dans l'intérêt des familles qui
sont en cours d'adoption à l'heure
actuelle et compte tenu effectivement de
l'effet destructeur qu'urit mon
amendement j'ai décidé de le
retirer bien l'amendement est retiré
nous passons à l'amendement 208 rectifié
bis de Monsieur
Milon je vais le je vais mettre cet
amendement au voie ceux qui sont
d'accord pour l'adopter le manifeste en
levant la main
pour ceux qui sont
contre
abstention l'amendement n'est pas adopté
amendement 238 de Mame Bassa demande de
retrait du gouvernement madame Bassa je
vous en
prie
retirer
merci amendement 211 rectifié bis de
Monsieur Milon ceux qui sont
pour
contre
abstention l'amendement n'est pas adopté
amendement 120 rectifié bis de Monsieur
rotillot ceux qui sont pour
pour
contre abstention l'amendement n'est pas
adopté 121 rectifi bis de Monsieur
rotaillot
pour ils sont tous
liés alors je recommence
121tif alors nous sommes sur le 121
rectifié B 164 rectifié 166 rectifié 202
251 pour lequel monsieur lu demande une
explication de vote
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je n'ai pas bien compris
lorsque vous avez répondu à l'ensemble
des argumentaires de notre de nos bans
euh votre réponse sur cet amendement-là
vous avez dit avis défavorable parce
qu'il propose l'interdiction de la GPA
nous n'avons jamais demandé dans ce
débat l'interdiction de la GPA on sait
bien qu'il n'est pas du ressort de ce
périmètre-là nous demandons à ce qu'il
ne soit pas autorisé d'adopter
dans le cadre d'un enfant qui aurait été
conçu dans le cadre d'une GPA donc votre
réponse était pas la bonne et moi
j'aimerais que vous me répondiez sur
cette question plus précisément parce
que je puisque personne ne veut de la
GPA démontrez-nous dès aujourd'hui qu'on
ne peut pas adopter un enfant qui serait
conçu par
GPA merci monsieur delè
merci monsieur le Président Madame les
ministre chers collègues mon explication
de de vote s'inscrit dans dans le
prolongement de ce que vient de nous
dire monsieur lu j'avoue que j'ai du mal
à
comprendre la logique qui nous a été
présentée par le rapporteur en gros il
nous
dit la jurisprudence de la Cour de
cassation règle le problème par
conséquent il y a pas lieu de l'inscrire
dans la loi mais je ne vois pas en quoi
si vous êtes si satisfait de la
jurisprudence de la Cour de cassation il
n'y aurait pas un intérêt à le préciser
dans la loi de telle sorte que nous nous
mettrions à l'abri de toute évolution de
la jurisprudence de la Cour de cassation
j'ajoute que
hier hier on a eu un débat sur la
définition du mariage et vous nous avez
expliqué que c'était
une cérémonie
républicaine on vous a dit oui
effectivement d'ailleurs toutes les lois
de la République sont par définition des
lois républicaines et c'est donc
redondant donc si vous
estimiez effectivement qu'il faut
respecter les engagement du Président de
la République je crois qu'il y aurait
tout intérêt à faire en sorte que cette
loi garantisse la possibilité au
président de la République de respecter
son
engagement merci la parole à Monsieur
Milon
oui monsieur le Président merci je
voulais revenir un petit peu sur sur ces
problèmes de PMA de convenance et de GPA
pour pour rappeler quand même que le
juge qui prononce l'adoption de l'enfant
du conjoint n'a pas à vérifier comment
l'enfant a été conçu si il y a PMA à
l'étranger et si l'enfant né en France
la mère est celle qui accouche donc
l'amendement de notre collègue becco ne
tient pas vraiment je voudrais aussi
rappeler que le recours à la GPA
interdit sur notre territoire national
l'adoption par la mère
d'intention mais si le père biologique
recours à la GPA à l'étranger rien ne
s'oppose à l'adoption par le mari du
père sauf si la GPA est affirmé mais si
le père dit qu'il a eu cet enfant avec
une femme qui a refusé d'en être la mère
l'adoption se fait sans problème il est
difficile de prouver la fraude et enfin
je voudrais juste rappeler à monsieur le
rapporteur qu'il a dit une chose qui me
semble fausse l'adoption pliniiaèire
n'interdit pas la connaissance des
origines la parole à Madame marie-thérèe
bruger
oui monsieur le Président madame le
garde des saau madame le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
sur la question du mariage des couples
de même sexe nous connaissons tous des
dissensions qui dépassent l'éclivage
politique droite gauche c'est un fait et
vous le savez bien les uns diront que
l'alliance d'une homme et d'une femme
est une chose naturelle les autres nous
diront que c'est naturel c'est ce qu'on
on observe c'est l'union dans notre
société de couples de même sexe je vais
assez vite pour arriver au principal je
respecte ces ces arguments je vais me
méplacer dans une autre posture je
considère que nous sommes là pour faire
un choix de société important ainsi
étant légitime pour défendre mon opinion
dans cette assemblée je ne m'exprime pas
au nom de certains lobby de certains
psychanalystes ou de certains
philosophes je défends là une conviction
profonde cette conviction me pousse à
voir à savoir quelle est la finalité du
mariage elle peut être pour certains ou
pour plus d'un million de Français elle
n'est pas elle n'a pas vocation de
reconnaître un lien affectif entre deux
personnes c'est une institution et on
l'a dit c'est une évidence telle que
l'altérité des sexueles n'a jamais été
remise en cause dans la succession des
textes qui l'ont réformé ce qui en fait
au passage et l'a expliqué le doyen
Géard un principe fondamental reconnu
par les lois de la République et cela
parce que tous les responsables
politiques ont depuis plus de 200 ans ad
demis qu'un enfant a besoin pour se
construire d'avoir auprès de lui un père
et une mère bien sûr qu'un enfant peut
être malheureux auprès de deux parents
de sexes différents mais cela ne met
rien en cause de ce que je viens
d'expliquer précédemment je crois je
sais c'est du résiné après souper je
sais je crois qu'un enfant qui vit avec
son père et sa mère a plus de chance
d'AV avoir une structure psychique
équilibrée parce qu'il n'aura plus
vraisemblablement accéder à la réponse
des questionnements qui le préoccupent
quant à son origine tout simplement nous
connaissons tous autour de nous des
adultes qui bien qu'étant ayant été
adopté cherchent et recherchent
indéfiniment leurs origines et souffrent
et j'en connais personnellement qui sont
jusqu'à leur mort ils rechercheront
leurs
père je veux dire
ce n'est pas une texte quelconque c'est
une opinion personnelle c'est un fait
incontestable un enfant a besoin autant
que possible d'avoir un papa une maman
nous le savons tous hélas hélas la vie
décide quelquefois autrement et je l'ai
vécu personnellement donc je suis
personnellement touchée je cite
Christian flavini psychanalyste
pédopsychiatre directeur du département
de psychanalyste de l'enfant et de
l'adolescent à l'hôpital de de la salle
pétrière qui s'exprimait dans le monde
le 9 novembre 2012 s'il est adopté ce
projet gouvernemental ouvrirait le
mariage à l'adoption de tous cela
validerait qu'un enfant pourrait de
droit n'avoir ni père ni mère il en
ressent une mésestime de lui-même les
preuves de l'enfin qui n'a jamais eu de
père et de mère et d'une intensité bien
plus vive à la limite de
l'inexprimable que le conjoint
homosexuel soit convoqué comme un
deuxième parent brouille sa réflexion et
place une figure factice sur celle
manquante du papa dans un artifice de
solution ou défaut du père le plaquage
comporterait une confusion nuisible à
l'équilibre de toutes les familles vous
vous trouverez
peut-être cette indifférenciation
dissipe le principe
fondateur de la vie familiale l'interdit
de l'inceste vous trouverez peut-être
que cet homme raconte n'importe quoi ce
n'est pas moi c'est un
psychanalyste il exerce ses compétences
qui sont loin d'être remise en cause
mais vous m'arrêterez pas merci de
terminer chers collègues merci monsieur
le Président merci bien sûr nous ne
voterons pas cet article bien sûr la
parole nous quittons l'hémicycle du
Sénat mais nous reviendrons bien entendu
plus largement sur l'examen de ce projet
de loi dans notre journal de 19h
présenté ce soir par Michel grossior
très bonne soirée à
tous